Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome to, smart glass, smart glass, smart glass, smart glass. I feel like I want to get into talking to you guys. I really do. I miss you. Sean, I owe you a call. I know that you phased out me the other night and I never called you back and I'm just realizing that now. That's okay. And I miss you desperately. I miss you guys too.
欢迎，欢迎，欢迎，欢迎，欢迎来到智能眼镜，智能眼镜，智能眼镜，智能眼镜。我觉得我想开始和你们说话。我真的想。我想你们。肖恩，我欠你一个电话。我知道你那天晚上不理我，我从来没回你电话，我刚刚才意识到。没关系。我非常想念你们。我也想念你们。
And are you okay in Chicago? Oh, William, thank you. Are you? I mean, it's other than the sirens going off every single, every fucking night. And the guy across the, across the hall from us has a dog and they leave their door open and it barks so loud, it sounds like it's in our apartment. And then it gets all the dogs down the whole, the whole hallway going, every dog starts barking. Have you talked to them about it or?
你在芝加哥还好吧？哦，威廉，谢谢你。你呢？我是说，除了每单，每个他妈的晚上都有警报器在响。我们对门，大厅对门的那个人养了一只狗，他们把门开着，它叫得太响了，听起来就像在我们公寓里一样。然后整条走廊里所有的狗都被带动了，每只狗都开始叫。你跟他们谈过这事吗，还是？
No. Giving them a hairy eyeball on the elevator at least? No, I don't. What are you guys about masks like people in this building? Dogs? They are carriers. No, like I do, like some people in the building don't wear masks anymore. And some people are like, oh, the mandate's over.
没有。在电梯里给他们甩个白眼总有吧？不，我没有。你们对这个大楼里的人戴口罩这事怎么看？狗？它们是带菌者。不，我是说，就像我一样，大楼里有些人不再戴口罩了。有些人觉得，哦，规定已经结束了。
So I would like to do it based on how they look like, ooh, you need a mask. You know what I mean? But what else? I always forget to bring a meal to rehearsal too. So I'm kind of hungry all the time. We only get 20 minute breaks. So if I run home, isn't this an amazing story? If I run home. Relatable. Maybe the soldiers in Ukraine would like to hear about your 20 minute breaks. Yeah, maybe they want to talk about your tech rehearsal. Snacks aren't great. Wait, are you going to start complaining about your blocking next?
所以我希望能根据他们的长相来决定，哦，你需要戴口罩。你知道我的意思吗？但还有什么？我总是忘记带饭去排练。所以我基本上随时都很饿。我们只有20分钟的休息时间。如果我跑回家，这不是一个神奇的故事吗？如果我跑回家。很有共鸣。乌克兰的士兵也许很想听听你20分钟休息时间的故事。对，也许他们想谈谈你的技术排练。零食不太好。等等，你接下来要开始抱怨你的走位了吗？
Yeah. Yes, I'll thank you for bringing that up. Wait, take it up with the director. We don't want to hear about the blocking on your plan. No, so I have 20 minutes. I don't know what to do. I never have, anyway, I'm always hungry. Yeah. Yeah, Jason. I don't have any complaints. I just feel for my fellow citizens around the world. Like what?
对。是的，谢谢你提起这个。等等，去找导演谈。我们不想在你的计划里听关于走位的抱怨。不，所以我有20分钟。我不知道该做什么。我从来不，总之，我总是很饿。对。对，杰森。我没有任何抱怨。我只是为全世界的同胞感到揪心。比如什么？
Sean, you would have loved it last night. I had Jason's wife, Amanda, here at the house and his daughter, Maple. But no, Jason. To have dinner with my, and not Jason. No. No, because, you know, because today is Saturday. Yesterday was a work day. So you're starting dinner at five o'clock. That means I still got two hours of work left. By the way, what a joke says this, says the guy who since January 1st has played 34 days of golf and none of them on the weekend, by the way, because he's not allowed to play on
肖恩，你昨晚一定会喜欢的。我把杰森的妻子阿曼达和他的女儿梅珀尔请到家里来了。但是不，杰森。和我一起吃晚餐，而没有杰森。不。不，因为，你知道的，因为今天是星期六。昨天是工作日。所以你五点钟就开始吃晚饭。这意味着我还有两个小时的工作没做。顺便说一句，真是个笑话，这话是谁说的，是一个自1月1st以来已经打了34天高尔夫球、而且顺便说一句没有一天是在周末打的人说的，因为他不被允许在
the weekend. We're going to talk about work days. Wait, isn't that a new, is that a new rule? It is a new rule. And I feel good about it. And I'm also a new rule is, this is also something our citizens in strife around the world. Does it have to do with your Tesla? Go ahead. No, it's, I'm, I'm going to not play every day. Okay.
周末打球。我们要谈论工作日吗？等等，这不是一个新，这是一个新规定吗？这是一个新规定。我对此感觉很好。而且还有一个新规定是，这也是我们世界各地处于水深火热中的同胞们的。这和你的特斯拉有关吗？说吧。不，我，我打算不每天都打。好吧。
Oh, wow. You know, the term hero gets used a lot, but I mean, in this case. Listen, we actors are, you know, it's not, we're not, it's, it's easy. Okay. And people that say, oh, it's so hard in the hours or so, please, we're so lucky to be doing what we're doing. Let me tell you something. When I run lines with Scotty, just from to memorize lines, run lines, Tracy is like, you run lines like you memorize lines.
哦，哇。你知道，英雄这个词经常被用到，但我的意思是，在这种情况下。听着，我们演员是，你知道的，这不，我们不是，这，这很简单。好吧。那些说，哦，时间太难熬了或者诸如此类的人，请吧，我们能做我们正在做的事是多么幸运。让我告诉你一件事。我和斯科蒂对台词时，仅仅是为了背台词、对台词，翠西就说，你对台词就像在背台词。
And he, I have such a short temper with him and it has nothing to do with him. But I'm like, okay, so I come in and I say, oh, relax. Okay. Then I say, but it's only four loud, lousy hours. What can go wrong? And he says, no, it's when I go, go back, go back to the previous line. Does he correct you on, on every word, every syllable? Yeah. And does he come to rehearsal and sit out in the audience?
而他，我对他的脾气很急，这跟他没有关系。但我会想，好吧，我进来然后说，哦，放松。好吧。然后我说，但只有四个喧闹的、糟糕的小时。能出什么岔子？他说，不，当我走，回到前一句台词去。他会纠正你的每个字、每个音节吗？对。他会来排练并坐在观众席里吗？
And does he, do you go line in Scotty's there? No, for the actual performances. Did you imagine? Can he maybe have like a fanny pack that's got snacks in it or something for you? I know. Can you make me a fanny pack with snacks? A pack snack. You know, it's almost like he's walking you.
他会吗，你跟斯科蒂对台词的时候他在吗？不，是正式演出的时候。你能想象吗？他能不能带个装有零食的小腰包什么的给你？我知道。你能给我做一个装零食的小腰包吗？零食包。你知道，这感觉就像他在遛你。
Like he's a dog walker, but for you and he's got a fanny pack and he could have some wipes and stuff. It's a snacky pack. Wipes. Scotty with a snacky pack. We tried to buy Shawn that toilet too. And then it wouldn't work, right? Yeah. But Jason and I wanted to buy you a fancy toilet.
就像他是遛狗员，但对象是你，他背着一个腰包，里面可以放些湿巾之类的东西。这是一个零食包。湿巾。带有零食包的斯科蒂。我们也试着给肖恩买那个马桶。然后它不管用，对吧？对。但杰森和我当时想给你买一个豪华马桶。
I know that was so nice. Yeah. Listener. So when we were on the tour, you'd learn a lot about someone when you're living with them. And sweet, sweet Shawn, as privileged as he sounds with this past five minutes, he was completely unaware that the toilets with the washlet has snuck up on him. And he'd never heard of it before. You know, those Toto toilets that like shoot a geyser in you. Well, no, I mean, people know about them.
我知道那太好了。好吧。听众朋友们。所以当我们去巡演时，和一个人生活在一起，你会对他有很多了解。甜美可爱的肖恩，尽管过去这五分钟里听起来他很有特权，但他完全不知道带冲洗功能的马桶已经悄悄走进了他的生活。他以前从未听说过那种东西。你知道那些会像喷泉一样向你喷水的Toto马桶吗？好吧，不，我是说，人们都知道它们。
Not a lot of people have them. But I mean, it's like, it's this bizarre new technology in. It's a bidet built into the bath. Yeah. So we tried to buy Jason and I tried to after learning of Shawn. Did it know his birthday? I came out of the bathroom. I was like in awe. I was like, oh my God, there's these switches that can clean your ass.
没有很多人拥有它们。但我的意思是，这就像是一种奇怪的新技术。它是内置在浴缸里的坐浴盆。对。所以我们在了解到肖恩的情况后，尝试着去买——杰森和我尝试去买。知道他的生日吗？我从浴室出来，我当时惊呆了。我当时想，哦，天哪，这些开关可以清洗你的屁股。
I can then blow dry. We were staying in a hotel that had one and he couldn't believe it. And we're like, come on. So we know that he, while he's away in Chicago, he's doing some remodeling in the castle there in LA. And so we tried to arrange with his husband to get a new toy toy put in there. And it ended up being more expensive than the toilet. Toy toy.
然后我还可以吹干。我们当时住在一个有这种马桶的酒店里，他简直不敢相信。我们当时想，得了吧。所以我们知道，当他在芝加哥时，他正在洛杉矶的城堡里进行一些装修。所以我们试图和他的老公安排，在那里装一个新的玩具马桶。结果发现它比马桶本身还要贵。玩具马桶。
You had to tear down the wall and they go into the pipes and everything. But it's the thought that counts. And you guys were so sweet to think of that. And I was going to get you guys porches, but I just didn't work out. Well, there's still time. There's still time. Maybe try again. It's a thought.
你得拆墙，他们得弄管道什么的。但礼轻情意重。你们俩能想到这一点真是太贴心了。我本来想给你们买门廊的，但就是没弄成。好吧，还来得及。还来得及。也许再试一次。这是个心意。
Speaking of still time, we're running out of time because we have a great guest here who has been really biding his time waiting and being so gracious. Sorry, that's my fault. And he, this is somebody who can relate to actor problems because this is a person who's been acting at a high level for longer than the three of us have ever, you know, even known what the hell was going on in the world. This is somebody who started on the stage, it's a great acclaim, moved into films, has made countless films over the year at the highest level.
说到还来得及，我们的时间不多了，因为我们这里有一位伟大的嘉宾，他一直在耐心等待，表现得非常优雅。抱歉，那是我的错。而且他，这是一位能够对演员的问题感同身受的人，因为这是一个在极高水平上进行表演的人，时间比我们三个知道世界上到底发生了什么还要长。这是一个从舞台起家、获得巨大赞誉、随后涉足电影界、多年来在最高水平上制作了无数电影的人。
Dick Van Dyke. Great performances, not Dick Van Dyke. Not only that, he and I have starred together as it turns out in three pictures together, which does only brings him down and props me up and makes me look good. Somebody that I've just admired for so long because he's such an incredible actor. And he's the star of the nut job, the nut job to the Lego movie. Also, perhaps Schindler's list that taken movies. Oh, good Lord.
迪克·范·戴克。精彩的表演，不是迪克·范·戴克。不仅如此，事实证明，他和我在三部影片中联袂主演过，这不仅没有拉低他的水平，反而抬高了我的身价，让我看起来很棒。这是一个我一直崇拜的人，因为他是一个如此不可思议的演员。他是《抢劫坚果店》、《抢劫坚果店2》、《乐高大电影》的主演。或许还有《辛德勒的名单》、《飓风营救》。哦，天哪。
If he's got a new film coming out memory, you guys, it's Mr. Liam Neeson. This is a real star. Liam Neeson. That's a real movie star. Wow. Right there. Hi, Sean. Wow, good morning.
如果他有一部新电影要上映，记忆，伙计们，这就是连姆·尼森先生。这是一位真正的明星。连姆·尼森。那可是一位真正的电影明星。哇。就在那儿。嗨，肖恩。哇，早上好。
Look at this. I did love listening to you. I did love listening to you. Sorry about that. Jason, you play golf. I have to tell you. I'm sorry. Only because I'm trying to understand how the common man lives his life.
你看这个。我确实很喜欢听你们说话。我确实很喜欢听你们说话。真是不好意思。杰森，你打高尔夫球。我不得不告诉你。我很抱歉。只是因为我试图理解普通人是如何生活的。
He's sorry for you. He said, did you hear that? He said that he already feels pity for you, Jason. I know. I'm embarrassed. But I do it for the mental anguish of it. To me, it's work. It's very hard to do.
他为你感到遗憾。他说，你听到了吗？他说他已经开始同情你了，杰森。我知道。我很尴尬。但我这么做是为了体会精神上的折磨。对我来说，这是工作。这很难做到。
Very believable. Anyway, I still don't thank you. As George Bernard Shaw once said, it's a good walk ruined. That's right. It's true. That's part of the job, trying to stay positive. We've had our first George Bernard Shaw quote. You have already classed us up a million percent, Liam.
非常可信。不管怎样，我仍然不，谢谢你。正如萧伯纳曾经说过的那样，这是一次被毁掉的美好散步。没错。确实如此。试图保持积极心态，这也是工作的一部分。我们已经迎来了第一个萧伯纳的名言。连姆，你已经把我们的格调提升了一百万倍。
Thank you so much for being here, man. It's such an incredible honor. I'm very honored myself, and I'm very, very fucking nervous. Don't be. Liam, let me start by this, because this is an area that Sean loves the most, which is our stories from the theater, and you have a long history of performing in the theater for many years. So, Sean, I'm going to give you the opportunity to right off the bat,
非常感谢你能来，老兄。这真是无上的荣誉。我自己也感到非常荣幸，而且我非常、非常他妈的紧张。别这样。连姆，让我从这里开始，因为这是肖恩最喜欢的领域，也就是我们在剧院的故事，你有着多年在剧院表演的悠久历史。所以，肖恩，我要给你一个机会，一开始就
ask Liam a theater question, your most prized theater question. Well, now I'm put on the spot. First of all, I can't believe I'm talking to you. I know. This is so awesome. This is so cool. And I'm nervous a little bit. So, my question to you is, what is your favorite tragic theater story?
问连姆一个关于剧院的问题，你最珍视的剧院问题。好吧，现在我被架在火上烤了。首先，我简直不敢相信我正在跟你说话。我知道。这太棒了。这太酷了。我有点紧张。所以，我给你的问题是，你最喜欢的悲剧剧院故事是什么？
I've said so many of mine on here. I'm trying to think of another one. Well, I can tell you another one. Kristen, I did a play with Kristen Chenoweth years ago. The listeners are so sick of me talking about it. And at the end of the show, we come up for our bows, and I look over from opposite wings, and Kristen and I are supposed to come from opposite sides of the stage,
我在这里已经讲过太多我自己的故事了。我在想另一个。好吧，我可以告诉你另一个。克里斯汀，我和克里斯汀·肯诺恩斯多年前一起演过一出戏。听众们都听烦我谈论这个了。在演出结束时，我们出来谢幕，我从对面的侧台看过去，克里斯汀和我应该从舞台的两侧出来，
meet in the middle, walk down the center, and take our bow together. Complicated. And I... Never seen that before. So, these are the curtain calls, huh? The bows, right? Okay. Did you bump into each other?
在中间会合，顺着中心走下来，一起谢幕。很复杂。我……从来没见过那样的。所以，这些是谢幕，对吧？谢幕，对吧？好吧。你们撞到彼此了吗？
How do you avoid that? What were your two characters' name? Promises and promises, right? Those are the two characters? Keep going, Sean. We're a classy guest. So, Kristen. So, I look over, and Kristen's not there,
你们怎么避免这种情况？你们两个角色的名字是什么？《承诺与承诺》，对吧？那是两个角色吗？继续，肖恩。我们可是有格调的嘉宾。所以，克里斯汀。所以，我望过去，克里斯汀不在那儿，
and I'm like, oh, my God, everybody's clapping waiting for us to come out. I'm like, where's Kristen? And I look over, and she's dead passed out on the side. On the floor, passed out on the floor. What? And I'm like, what the hell happened to Kristen Chenoweth? And so, I'm like, Sageman,
我就想，哦，天哪，大家都拍着手等着我们出来呢。我就想，克里斯汀呢？然后我望过去，她竟然死死地晕倒在旁边。在地上，晕倒在地上。什么？我当时想，克里斯汀·肯诺恩斯到底怎么了？所以我当时想，萨奇曼，
and I'm like, do I go out? Do I wait for her? What's happening? They're trying to revive her, get her back up. So, I went out and took my bow by myself, and turned out she... You were thinking, wow, I'm getting double the applause. So, then...
我就想，我要出去吗？我要等她吗？发生什么事了？他们正试图抢救她，让她醒过来。所以我走出去自己谢幕，结果她……你当时在想，哇，我得到了双倍的掌声。所以，然后……
What happened to her? She passed out because she didn't eat that day. So, they gave her a candy bar, and she came back to... She did a whole show, and then passed out at the end. Oh, my gosh. When is the last time you did a live theater show? Oh, my God. 14 years ago, I did a little Samuel Beckett piece called
她怎么了？她晕倒了是因为她那天没吃东西。所以他们给了她一块糖，然后她恢复了……她演完了整场演出，然后在最后晕倒了。哦，天哪。你上一次做现场剧院演出是什么时候？哦，天哪。14年前，我演过一个很小的塞缪尔·贝克特的剧目，叫做
A. Joe. It lasts about 25 minutes. I don't say a word. That's one of the reasons I took the job. And Ray Fiennes was... It was an evening of Beckett pieces at Lincoln Center. That was the last time. And do you want to do it again?
《艾。乔》。大约持续25分钟。我一句话都不说。这也是我接这份工作的原因之一。拉尔夫·费因斯当时是……那是林肯中心的一个贝克特剧目之夜。那是最后一次。你还想再演吗？
Or you're like, I'm good. No, the muse has gone from me. It's left me completely. Really? Yeah. And I don't... I used to worry about it because I started off in the theater for four years, just nothing but theater.
还是你会觉得，我算了吧。不，缪斯已经抛弃我了。它彻底离开我了。真的吗？是的。而且我不会……我以前很担心这个，因为我刚开始在剧院里干了四年，除了剧院什么都没有。
Did the odd play, and the crucible, and the Beckett piece, and then about three, four years ago, it just... The muse just left me. I was offered some stuff, and it's just... I love seeing my friends do it. I love... You're talking about the muse for theater. Muse for theater.
偶尔演个话剧，《萨勒姆的女巫》，还有贝克特的那部作品，然后大约三、四年前，它就……缪斯就离开我了。有人找我演过一些东西，但它就是……我喜欢看我的朋友们演。我喜欢……你是在说剧院的缪斯。剧院的缪斯。
Yeah. Yes, just, yeah. You know, I hear people say that about theater because the schedule is really, really challenging. But the movies you are doing... Are so demanding. ...are... You cannot ask for a harder genre for you to do,
是的。是的，就是，是的。你知道，我听到人们对剧院这样说，因为演出日程真的、真的很具挑战性。但你正在拍的电影……要求太高了。……是……你简直不能要求一个对你来说更难的电影类型了，
and you do it... I can understand maybe one out of every five films you're out there doing all the action stuff. But my God, the amount of stamina that you must have and work ethic you have and discipline that you have and the shape you must be in, it's so incredibly admirable. Well, thank you, sir. A nice little three-act drama down the street.
而你却做到了……我可以理解也许你拍的五部电影里有一部是这种动作戏。但是天哪，你必须具备的那种耐力、工作伦理、纪律性以及你必须保持的体形，这实在是太令人钦佩了。好吧，谢谢你，先生。街头的一部精彩的三幕剧。
I mean, come on. You need a break. Yeah, I... Maybe some little farce comedy, you know? Some sort of French farce, you know? Noises on. Yeah, a bunch of doors slamming, a bunch of grab-ass. Yeah, that stuff's hard to do.
我是说，拜托。你需要休息一下。对，我……也许来点小闹剧喜剧，你知道吗？某种法国闹剧，你知道吗？《糊涂戏班》。对，一堆门砰砰关上，一堆乱七八糟的打闹。对，那些东西很难演。
Is this to it? Or get yourself a podcast, Liam. Oh, God. Come on. Look how cozy this is. Liam, I'm going to tell you something. I'm 51, almost 52, and I... He plays 36.
就是这样吗？或者给自己弄个播客，连姆。哦，天哪。拜托。看这里多舒服。连姆，我要告诉你一件事。我51岁，快52岁了，我……他演36岁的。
He plays 36, looking at you. Well, we won't talk about age, but I'll tell you this. I read a script the other day. They said, take a look at this. They said they're interested. And I read it in the first scene said, Exterior Night. And I said, I'm not interested.
他看着你，演36岁的。好吧，我们不谈年龄，但我会告诉你这个。我前几天看了一个剧本。他们说，看一看这个。他们说他们感兴趣。我在第一场戏里读到：“外景，夜晚”。我说，我不感兴趣。
That's a true story. Liam doesn't care about that. Yeah, I mean, it does take a lot of those films you do. Look, we've all done it. You know, it takes a village, right? Yeah. I have a little routine when I'm doing one. I get up, I exercise for 30, 35 minutes, maximum.
这是一个真实的故事。连姆才不在乎那个呢。是的，我是说，你拍的那些电影确实需要付出很多。看，我们都拍过。你知道，这需要整个团队的努力，对吧？对。我在拍戏时有一个小套路。我起床，锻炼30、35分钟，最多。
That's it. No more than that. And, you know, when you're doing the junkets and stuff, say, oh, you do your own stunts. And I always say to them, please listen to me. I do not do my own stunts. I don't do that at all. I do my own fighting.
就这样。不会超过那个时间。而且，你知道，当你做宣传采访之类的时候，他们会说，哦，你都是自己做特技吗？我总是对他们说，请听我说。我不是自己做特技。我根本不做那些。我自己打斗。
That I like to do. But stunts, no. You know, jumping out of windows and falling over too. Wait, wait, wait. So you're doing your own fighting? Yeah, the fighting's no bargain. That's not simple. Yeah, but it's like learning a dance, Jason.
我喜欢做那个。但特技，不。你知道，从窗户跳出去然后摔倒之类的。等等，等等，等等。所以你自己打斗？对，打斗可不是什么好差事。那可不简单。对，但这就像学一支舞蹈，杰森。
Yeah, but I did actually the last big fight I did was with Will Arnett on Arrested Development. And it was supposed to be, it was supposed to be funny because it lasted so long. You know, two idiots that don't really know how to fight. They just end up on the floor wrestling. And they kept cutting back to the scene and we're still throwing. So we had to shoot it over the course of like,
对，但我拍的最后一场大型打斗戏其实是和威尔·阿奈特在《发展受阻》里拍的。本该是，本该是挺搞笑的，因为持续时间太长了。你知道，两个根本不知道怎么打架的笨蛋。他们最后倒在地上扭打。他们不断切回这个场景，而我们还在打。所以我们不得不拍了大约，
I don't know, it was like a 15-minute fight. It literally put me in the hospital. We had to shut down for a few weeks because I was so exhausted. And this was 20 years ago. I'm allowed to handle. You'd say that. You're allowed to. You got a real back on you.
我不知道，就像是一场15分钟的打斗。这差点把我送进医院。我们不得不停拍几个星期，因为我太累了。那是20年以前的事了。我能应付。你会这么说的。你行的。你确实很有底子。
Sure. Yeah. You play golf every day. I play golf. You fit. Now I only play nine holes a day. I can't walk 18. No, that's not true.
当然。是的。你天天打高尔夫球。我打高尔夫球。你身材保持得很好。现在我一天只打九个洞。我走不了18洞。不，那不是真的。
But Jay, I asked you about that last, the last episode of the latest Ozark Chunk. Yes. Where the guy comes in and beats the crap out of you. I'm like, was that you? And you're like, no, are you fucking kidding me? No, I, for a while there, I kind of thought, oh no, I'm going to, if there's some kind of a stunt,
但是，杰·杰森，我问过你关于那个，最新一季《黑钱胜地》最后一集的事情。是的。有个家伙进来把你狠狠揍了一顿。我当时想，那是你吗？你说，不，你在开什么玩笑吗？不，我，有一段时间我甚至想，哦不，如果有什么特技的话，
I want to do it. And then a stunt coordinator took me aside one day and he said, hey guy, I know you're trying to do the right thing for a camera and everything, but having it be your face. But you know, you're taking money out of this guy's pocket over here. He was just standing on the set, ready to double you. That's true. And he gets paid for every take.
我想亲自上。然后有一天一个特技协调员把我拉到一边对我说，嘿，伙计，我知道你想为镜头和一切做出正确的表现，而且这也是你的脸。但你知道，你这是在抢这个家伙口袋里的钱。他当时就站在片场，准备替你上场。确实如此。而且他每个镜头都能拿报酬。
So if you just sit there and try to be a hero, this guy's trying to make a living too. And I was like, oh. So I learned that lesson early on at Liam. I'm sure you learned it way before. And he's going to make it look good. Exactly. Yeah, it's going to make you look good.
所以如果你只是坐在那里想当英雄，这个家伙也得谋生。当时我就想，哦。所以我很早就从连姆那里吸取了这个教训。我相信你早就学会了。而且他会让你看起来很棒。没错。是的，他会让你看起来很棒。
Yeah, on top of it all. Yeah. So when Will kind of said that you guys are on nut jobs up, you've got to look for some of those jobs, sometimes that are nice and cushy, maybe just with a microphone preferably like an animated film. But even if it's on camera, maybe some sort of nice domestic, you know,
是的，最重要的是。是的。所以当威尔说你们在《抢劫坚果店》合作过时，你得找一些那样的工作，有时那些工作挺舒适惬意的，最好带个麦克风，比如动画电影。但即使是真人出镜，也许某种不错的家庭，你知道，
dramedy or something. Yeah, but I don't get to kill people, you know. You could have a dream sequence right in the middle of like a Thanksgiving dinner, you know. That's true, yes. Liam, wait, you touched on something I wanted to ask you about, which was, you know, obviously you've done tons and tons of such phenomenal work in your life and your career.
剧情喜剧什么的。对，但我没有机会杀人，你知道的。你可以在感恩节晚宴的正中间来一段梦境。那是真的，是的。连姆，等等，你刚才提到了我想问你的一件事，那就是，显然你一生和职业生涯中做过无数非常出色的工作。
And you know, one of the biggest ones out of all of them was of course, Schindler's List and with Ray Fiennes. And then here I am years and years later watching Clash of the Titans. And it wasn't until the end of the movie, I was like, oh wait, those two were in Schindler's List too. That's how great you are. Completely forgot that you both were in another movie together.
你知道，其中最大的一部当然是《辛德勒的名单》，和拉尔夫·费因斯一起。然后几年后，我在这里看《诸神之战》。直到电影快结束时，我才想，哦等等，这两个人也在《辛德勒的名单》里。这就是你有多伟大。完全忘了你们俩还一起演过另一部电影。
And so do you have a relationship with Ray? Did you know him? Did you build a family? Ray is a really, really good friend. But I remember when we shot that, that was the first, we did two at Clash of the Titans and Wrath of the Titans, was it? Yeah.
所以你和拉尔夫有联系吗？你认识他吗？你们建立过家庭吗？拉尔夫是一个真的、真的很不错的朋友。但我记得我们拍那部戏的时候，那是第一部，我们拍了两部，《诸神之战》和《诸神之怒》，对吧？对。
And the first one was nearly 13 years ago. But when Ray comes on, he's playing Hades, you know, the God of Hell. And I'm Zeus, the God of Gods. He comes and he's my brother. I couldn't do the scene with him. I couldn't look him straight in the eyes. I had to keep looking at his forehead.
第一部差不多是13年前了。但当拉尔夫出场时，他扮演哈迪斯，你知道的，地狱之神。而我是宙斯，众神之神。他来了，他是我的兄弟。我没法和他演对手戏。我无法直视他的双眼。我只能一直盯着他的额头看。
Why? Why? To make you laugh? Why? Because he kept cracking you up? Well, we just, you know, we're dressed in wigs and beards and all that stuff. And it's like, it's like, oh, come on.
为什么？为什么？为了让你笑吗？为什么？因为他一直逗你笑吗？好吧，我们只是，你知道，我们都戴着假发和胡子之类的。然后那种感觉就像是，哦，拜托。
It was so good. I couldn't do the scene with him. I just had to keep looking at his forehead. There are people that you have that kind of relationship with. There's that kind of chemistry that they just make you laugh. And when I was doing a recipe, it was Tony Hale who played Buster. And we would often come into a scene together. And so we'd be on our start mark and we would be looking at us
太棒了。我没法和他演对手戏。我只能一直盯着他的额头看。有些人你和他们就有那种关系。有一种化学反应，他们就是能逗你笑。当我拍《发展受阻》时，托尼·海尔饰演巴斯特。我们经常一起进到一场戏里。所以我们会站在我们的起始位置上，我们会看着我们
about to give us our cue. And like right as you could hear the dialogue, we're about to get the cue. Tony would immediately kind of go into his character of Buster. All of a sudden, he'd be standing there. Kind of tuck his chin. And he'd go. Raise his eyebrows.
准备给我们 cue。就在你能听到台词、我们正要得到 cue 的那一刻，托尼会立刻进入他的巴斯特角色。突然之间，他就站在那儿了。把下巴收一收。然后他会。扬起眉毛。
Ooh, like this. Get ready. And as soon as he did that, I couldn't stop laughing. So I'd come into scenes laughing already. Because I've just coerced offstage. You know what I mean? Oh, God. Now, speaking of people that are unprofessional and can't keep it together,
哦，就像这样。准备好。他一做那个动作，我就笑得停不下来。所以我走进片场时就已经在笑了。因为我在后台就被逗笑了。你知道我的意思吗？哦，天哪。说到那些不够专业、自己都憋不住笑的人，
Laura Linney, your friend. Boy, we finally got through that show. How have you managed to stay friends with somebody that undisciplined and untalented for so many years? I know. I know. Come here. So when am I going to see series three, part two?
劳拉·琳妮，你的朋友。天哪，我们终于熬过那部剧了。你怎么能和一个如此没有纪律、毫无才华的人做这么多年朋友？我知道。我知道。过来。那我什么时候能看到第三季第二部分？
I've seen part one. I've seen. I love the show, by the way. This is of Ozark. Ozark. Ozark. Ozark. Thank you.
我看过第一部分了。我看过。顺便说一句，我很喜欢这部剧。这是《黑钱胜地》。《黑钱胜地》。《黑钱胜地》。《黑钱胜地》。谢谢。
Yes. No, it's coming the end of April. And of April. When this is going to air, but probably right about now. And that, Laura, my goodness, is she good? Yes. She's, you guys have been friends for many, many, many years, right? Yeah.
是的。不，它将在四月底播出。四月底。当这个节目播出时，大概也就是这个时候。还有劳拉，天哪，她怎么能这么优秀？是的。你们俩已经做了很多很多年的朋友了吧，对吧？对。
And she's got so many great stories about you. And I'll bet you of her. But, you know, it's just, sorry, listener, for just a second. Listen, the listener can relate to this. Anybody in any working experience, work environment, if you love the people that you work with, you don't spend a minute working ever. Right.
她有那么多关于你的精彩故事。我敢说你也有她的。但是，你知道，这只是，听众朋友们，对不起，打扰一会儿。听着，听众们会对这个产生共鸣。任何人在任何工作经验、工作环境中，如果你热爱和你一起工作的人，你一分钟的工作都不会觉得是在工作。对。
And she was just so incredible in sort of washing the whole set with her good vibes and positivity and warmth. Do you think she'd say the same about you? No. No, no. Between the two of us we had, we got to something right in the middle. You guys work together originally. Is that how you met?
她真的太棒了，用她那種良好的氣場、樂觀和溫暖感染了整個劇組。你覺得她會這樣評價你嗎？不會。不，不會。我們倆之間，我們找到了某種正中間的平衡點。你們本來就是一起合作的。你們是那樣認識的嗎？
Yeah. I'm trying to think. Yeah. Am I totally forgetting a big thing you guys did together? Or was it just a social? No, we did The Crucible on Broadway. Okay. And then we did a film called Kinsey.
對。我努力回想一下。對。我是不是完全忘了一件你們一起做過的大事？還是一次社交聚會？不，我們一起演了百老匯的《嚴峻的考驗》。好的。然後我們拍了一部叫《金賽性學教室》的電影。
Yes. And Laura was my wife in that. And then we did another film with Antonio Banderas. She was having an affair with him. She cheated on me in Ozark too. I love that Liam is still angry about it. It's just a movie. Especially Antonio Banderas.
對。勞拉在裡面演我的妻子。然後我們和安東尼·班德拉斯拍了另一部電影。她跟他在片中有一腿。她在《黑錢勝地》裡也對我不忠。我喜歡利安到現在還在生氣。這只是一部電影。特別是安東尼·班德拉斯。
He's so ugly. I was like, come on. It's the homework of a, I don't want to embarrass you, Liam, but it's a homework of a great movie star that you barely remember how many movies you've done or what they are. And for us, like as sort of like fans, we're like, this is so exciting to have somebody who... Well, do you know something?
他長得太醜了。我當時就想，拜託。這是個……我不想讓你難堪，利安，但這是一個偉大電影明星的基本功，你幾乎都不記得自己拍過多少電影，或者它們是什麼。而對我們來說，作為粉絲，我們會覺得，能有這樣一個人……好吧，你知道嗎？
I'm not blowing smoke up my ass here. Just prior to Christmas past, I finished my 100th film. No way. Wow. Wow. That's crazy. Tony Hopkins used to say, anytime we see each other, give each other a hug.
我這可不是在自吹自擂。就在去年聖誕節前夕，我完成了我的第100部電影。真的假的。哇。哇。太瘋狂了。安東尼·霍普金斯以前常說，每次我們見面，都要給對方一個擁抱。
And I say, who's it going, Tony? I'm not great. He says, I haven't been found out yet. I feel the exact same. But Liam, I'm not great at math here, but if you did four movies a year for 25 years in a row, that would give you 100 films. So, I mean, to do... Listener, you know, doing a film as an actor is a three month shoot.
我會說，最近怎麼樣，安東尼？我不太好。他說，我還沒被識破呢。我也有同感。但是利安，我數學不太好，但如果你連續25年每年拍四部電影，那就是100部電影。所以，我的意思是……聽眾朋友，你知道，作為一個演員，拍一部電影要三個月的拍攝期。
So if you did four, I mean, that's working 12 months a year, every year for 25 years. No, not really. I mean, I started... My first little film was 1977, Jason. Yeah. So little parts count, obviously. Oh, yeah.
所以如果你拍了四部，我的意思是，那就意味著連續25年，每年12個月都在工作。不，不完全是。我的意思是，我開始……我的第一部小電影是在1977年，傑森。對。所以小角色也算數，顯然。哦，對。
Was that in Ireland, or were you living in England when you did your first film? I wanted to get into this. I was actually living in Belfast. I was in the theatre. There were bombs and armored cars going... It was just like... Yeah, yeah, yeah.
那是愛爾蘭，還是你拍第一部電影時住在英國？我想聊聊這個。我當時其實住在貝爾法斯特。我在劇院工作。當時到處都是炸彈和裝甲車在……簡直就像……對，對，對。
You know, it's... It was a bit like Ukraine. I can imagine at the minute. Yeah. And we were in... I was in this theatre called the Lyric Players Theatre, and we played six nights a week during the height of the troubles. That theatre never closed.
你知道，這……這有點像現在的烏克蘭。我可以想象當時的情景。對。我們當時在……我在一個叫「抒情演員劇院」的劇院，在動盪最劇烈的時候，我們一週演六場。那家劇院從來沒關過門。
A couple of times there were bomb scares. Wow. Soldiers would come in. We'd have to go out onto the street with the audience. Okay, all clear. And go back and do the show. And what is that experience like? Because for us, obviously, we're such pampered guys
有好幾次都有炸彈恐慌。哇。士兵會進來。我們得和觀眾一起走到街上。好吧，一切正常。然後回去繼續演出。那種經歷是怎麼樣的？因為對我們來說，很明顯，我們是被寵壞的傢伙，
who have not had to experience anything like that. But to do a play in an environment like that, it must feel so far apart. Does it even feel like show business, or does it feel like you're... What is your mindset doing a play day in and day out with real threat just outside the doors? Well, my mindset was I was just so thrilled to be acting
從來沒有經歷過那樣的事情。但在那樣的環境下演話劇，一定感覺離現實很遠。這甚至感覺像是演藝圈嗎？還是覺得你……門外就有真實的威脅，你日復一日地演話劇，心態是什麼樣的？好吧，我的心態是，我太高興能演戲了，
and getting paid for it. And it was literally as simple as that. I was 24 when I turned professional and stalled pretty much a kid. All this shit was happening out in the streets and stuff. But I don't know. I felt I was in a bubble, my own bubble of joy doing these plays. We did a different play every four weeks, you know?
而且還能有薪水。事情就是這麼簡單。我24歲成為職業演員，基本上還是個孩子。所有這些爛事都在大街上發生著之類的。但我不知道。我覺得自己身處一個泡沫中，一個屬於我自己的快樂泡沫裡，演著這些話劇。我們每四周就演一齣不同的話劇，你知道嗎？
Wow. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. So there at 24, who was the Liam Neeson for you at 24? Who were you looking at and going, my God, if I could have a career that lasts that long and hold that amount of relevance that long and be at the top of my game at that age,
哇。我們馬上回來。現在，回到節目中。所以在24歲的時候，對你來說，誰是24歲時的利安·尼遜？你在看誰，然後想，天哪，如果我能擁有那麼長的職業生涯，保持那麼長時間的影響力，並且在那個年齡達到事業的巔峰，
now that I'm 24, I hope to be that age doing that. Well, who was that North Star for you at that point? God, that's a good question. Well, certainly my ambition then would have been... I mean, it wasn't... I never thought of movies at all. Really? I was unattainable for some reason.
既然我已經24歲了，我希望到那個年紀時也能那樣。好吧，當時誰是你的北極星？天哪，這真是個好問題。嗯，當然我那時的野心會是……我的意思是，這不是……我從來沒想過拍電影。真的嗎？出於某種原因，我覺得那是遙不可及的。
But I thought, oh, wouldn't it be great to be in Britain's national theatre as a regular player, you know? That was about that. Who was the big shot in the national theatre at that point? Was it... Does it go back too far to say John Gilgoode? Maggie Smith, Judy Dench, Robert Stevens, Colin Blakely, who was my hero, he was from the north of Ireland too.
但我想，哦，能成為英國國家劇院的常駐演員不是很棒嗎，你知道嗎？差不多就是這樣。當時國家劇院的大人物是誰？是……現在說約翰·吉爾古德會不會太久遠了？瑪姬·史密斯、茱蒂·丹契、羅伯特·史蒂文斯、柯林·布萊克利，他是我的偶像，他也是來自愛爾蘭北部。
But it was... Yeah, it was that. It was based on theatre. Was Albert Finney doing work in the national theatre at that point? No, 1976 he did a Hamlet, which was very, very good, which I saw. Oh, that, my God. Yeah, it just seems... I've just been so lucky, Jason.
但這是……對，就是那樣。那是基於戲劇的。亞伯特·芬尼當時在國家劇院工作嗎？沒有，1976年他演過《哈姆雷特》，非常非常棒，我看過。哦，天哪。對，這似乎……我真的是太幸運了，傑森。
I genuinely mean that. But you're doing theatre and you say... And I'm glad Jason brought that up. And you said that you never had any ambition to do movies that felt like just probably so far away from where you were at that time. Sure. But then you do a film in Belfast, your first film. And then the first time you're on a movie set, do you think like,
我是真心這麼覺得的。但你一直在演戲，你說……我很高興傑森提出了這個話題。你說你從來沒有想過拍電影，那感覺離你當時的處境可能太遙遠了。確實。但隨後你在貝爾法斯特拍了一部電影，你的第一部電影。然後你第一次在電影片場時，你會覺得，
yeah, I could see... This seems about right. Did it feel comfortable? No, I didn't have that. The first movie was for an evangelical outreach who were making a film in Belfast, believe it or not, of Pilgrim's Progress. Wow. John Bunyan's Pilgrim's Progress.
是的，我可以看到……這似乎挺合適的。感覺舒適嗎？不，我沒有那種感覺。第一部電影是一個福音派傳教團體拍的，他們在貝爾法斯特拍一部電影，信不信由你，拍的是《天路歷程》。哇。約翰·班揚的《天路歷程》。
And apparently the little film is still touring African stuff, you know, to get converts and stuff. Oh, wow. The evangelical religion. And I remember there's a place called Cave Hill that sort of overlooks the city of Belfast. And I was playing Jesus Christ. Sure.
顯然這部小電影現在還在非洲等地巡迴放映之類的，你知道的，為了爭取信徒什麼的。哦，哇。福音派宗教。我記得有一個地方叫凱夫山，差不多可以俯瞰貝爾法斯特市。我當時扮演耶穌基督。確實。
And I'm actually... I'm crucified. So I was on a cross with a fake crown of thorns and stuff in my hands with makeup, you know, false nails stuck in them and stuff. And I remember thinking, why are they not rolling the camera? Why are they not saying action and stuff? And they were all... The team of the evangelical people, they were all praying.
我其實……我被釘在十字架上。所以我掛在十字架上，戴著假的荊棘王冠，手裡化著妝，你知道的，插著假指甲之類的。我記得當時在想，他們為什麼不開機？他們為什麼不喊Action之類的？他們都在……福音派的那群人，他們都在祈禱。
Oh, wow. I was down there and I was like, my arms were getting so shaky. And I'm looking down at Belfast and I'm seeing armored cars going up and down and sirens going and stuff and saying, this is fucking crazy. But I love it. Yearning for a nice little one act. Yes. And you're thinking, I finally made it.
哦，哇。我站在那裡，心想，我的胳膊變得好顫抖。我低頭看著貝爾法斯特，看到裝甲車開來開去，警笛聲響起之類的，然後心想，這他媽太瘋狂了。但我喜歡。渴望一個精彩的小獨幕劇。是的。然後你心想，我終於成功了。
Yeah. Yes. That's so funny. So then you moved to England and you start your film career in England really in earnest at that point. Yeah, I mean, that was... No, I moved on to Dublin and was fortunate enough to do a couple of plays there. And then I joined the Abbey Theatre, which was Ireland, is Ireland's national theatre, I guess.
嗯。是的。太搞笑了。所以後來你搬到了英國，從那時起真正開始了你在英國的電影生涯。對，我的意思是，那是……不，我搬到了都柏林，很幸運在那裡演了幾部話劇。然後我加入了阿比劇院，那是愛爾蘭的國家劇院，我想是的。
I was there for a while and I did a production of Steinbeck's of Mice and Man. Yes. John Borman, the film director, who lives in Ireland, he came to see it and he was putting together this film, Excalibur by Arthurian legends. And he asked me what I play, Sir Gawain. And I was in this film with the shining suits of armour, myself, my best buddy, Kieran Hines. Wow. It was a lot.
我在那裡待了一陣子，演了一齣史坦貝克的《人與鼠》。是的。電影導演約翰·鮑曼，他住在愛爾蘭，他來看這部劇，當時他正在籌備電影《神劍》——亞瑟王傳說。他問我想演什麼，高文爵士。我和我最好的死黨基蘭·海因斯一起拍了這部電影，身上穿著閃亮的盔甲。哇。這很不簡單。
And the bug really got me there. I thought this is just the best. But it must be tough. I mean, you start your first film role, you're playing Jesus. I mean, everything after that is kind of a step down. I mean, when he comes to you, he says, do you want to play this night? You're like, guy, I was Jesus in the last one. How do you prepare an audition to play Jesus?
我從那時起真的迷上了拍電影。但這一定很難。我的意思是，你拍第一部電影時演的是耶穌。我的意思是，之後的一切都有點走下坡路了。我的意思是，當他來找你，問你想不想演這個角色時，你可能會想，老兄，上一部我可是耶穌啊。你怎麼為試鏡扮演耶穌做準備？
I'm practicing your faces in the mirror playing Jesus Christ. I would not really know where to go. How did he even research that? I don't know how I can see the gentleman's face, Mr. Anderson. I think it was Ken Anderson who was in charge of this little outreach. And I didn't do an audition. I just met him and he knew I was Catholic. I was Catholic and we never really spoke about professional questions.
我在鏡子裡練習扮演耶穌基督時的表情。我真的不知道該從何下手。他到底是怎麼做功課的？我不知道我怎麼能見到那個人，安德森先生。我想是肯·安德森負責這個小型傳教活動。我沒有去試鏡。我只是見了他一面，他知道我是天主教徒。我是天主教徒，我們從來沒有真正談過專業問題。
And this shoot was only about three weeks or something. You just reminded me there. I had a vision of, Will, didn't you play Jesus Christ unarrested for one of your illusions? Didn't Job had some sort of a religious themed illusion? And I remember you in some sort of a loincloth. Yeah, and then I went into the cave and I was going to come back. And then I got stuck in there. And started whining.
這次拍攝只用了大約三個星期左右。你剛才提醒了我，我腦海中浮現出一個畫面，威爾，你不是在你的某個魔術中未受審判地扮演過耶穌基督嗎？喬布斯是不是有過某種宗教主題的魔術？我記得你穿著某種遮羞布。對，然後我走進山洞，打算再出來。結果我被困在裡面了。然後開始抱怨。
Yeah, it was a very, not a very well thought out illusion by my character. And you ate nothing but plums and turnips for a few weeks just to prepare for that scene, right? They ended up finding me because I got, there was a false sort of back on the cave that I put on the stage. And then they ended up, they were one of those storage facilities. And they were doing one of those foes, those shows where they go into storage facilities and they auction off all the stuff. And they find this rock and they find me living in there sort of months later. Even thinner. In this cave.
對，這是一個被我的角色設計得不太周全的魔術。為了準備那場戲，你幾週裡只吃李子和蕪菁，對吧？他們最後找到了我，因為我……山洞背面有一個我安放在舞臺上的假後壁。然後他們最終發現我時，那是一個倉儲設施。他們正在拍那種節目，就是去倉儲設施拍賣裡面所有的東西。然後他們找到了這塊石頭，幾個月後發現我住在裡面。變得更瘦了。在這個山洞裡。
And I was very thin at the time. But Liam, you mentioned Tony Hopkins and for Tracy in Wisconsin. By the way, Liam, if you're not, I don't imagine you're a listener of the podcast, but Tracy is Sean's sister in Wisconsin. So anytime we mentioned something that people might not know, we talked to Tracy and explained to her. Specifically the inside baseball of showbiz. Yeah, so Tracy, Tony Hopkins is Sir Anthony Hopkins. And you work together the first time I imagine on The Bounty, is that right?
我當時確實很瘦。但利安，你提到了托尼·霍普金斯和威斯康辛州的崔西。順便說一句，利安，如果你不是——我想你應該不是這個播客的聽眾——但崔西是肖恩在威斯康辛州的妹妹。所以每當我們提到一些人們可能不知道的事情時，我們都會跟崔西交談並向她解釋。特別是演藝圈的內幕。對，所以崔西，托尼·霍普金斯就是安東尼·霍普金斯爵士。我想你們第一次合作是在《叛艦喋血記》裡，是這樣嗎？
That's right. It was The Bounty and we shot it in Mariah, which is an island, beautiful island just off Tahiti. And oh my God, I turned 31, so I turned 78 in June of this year. So that's a bunch of years ago. First of all, you look incredible. Please let me be. Yeah. Yeah, you look incredible.
沒錯。那是《叛艦喋血記》，我們在莫雷亞島拍攝的，那是一個離大溪地不遠的美麗島嶼。哦，天哪，我當時31歲，所以我今年6月就78歲了。所以那是好多年以前的事了。首先，你看起來狀態好極了。請讓我……對。對，你狀態好極了。
But I know. So you meet, so you're there and you've only made a few films at that point. Am I right? You made sort of five or six films? Yeah, I'd done some stuff in Ireland and some mini series in England. But now you're there and you're in Tahiti with Tony Hopkins and Mel Gibson? Tony and Mel, Daniel Day, Lewis, are a bunch of great British actors. You had trouble casting it, huh?
但我知道。所以你們相遇了，你在那時只拍了幾部電影。我沒說錯吧？你大概拍了五、六部電影？對，我在愛爾蘭拍過一些東西，在英國拍過一些迷你劇。但現在你在那裡，在大溪地，和托尼·霍普金斯以及梅爾·吉布森在一起？托尼和梅爾、丹尼爾·戴-路易斯，還有ㄧ群優秀的英國演員。你們選角遇到麻煩了吧？
Real trouble, but you made do. What was that experience like making that? I loved that. I bring it up just because I loved that film so much. I remember as a youth I watched it many times. Oh, gosh. Yeah, it was good. It was six day weeks and we all just loved Tony because he, as well as been, you know,
確實有麻煩，但你們還是湊合著完成了。拍那部電影的經歷是怎樣的？我很喜歡。我提起它只是因為我太喜歡那部電影了。我記得年輕時我看過很多遍。哦，天哪。對，挺不錯的。那是每週工作六天，我們所有人都很喜歡托尼，因為他除了扮演好……
Captain Bligh, he played brilliantly. He took care of us. He took care of his crew. And a lot of the crew were guys just fresh out of drama school in England, you know. First job and there you are in Tahiti, you know. But Tony just took care of us and I'll never forget that quality he had. And we had a great director, Roger Donaldson from New Zealand. But he and Tony didn't get on terribly well because he would do endless takes.
布萊·威廉船長這個角色之外，他表現得極其出色。他照顧我們。他照顧劇組的工作人員。很多工作人員都是剛從英國戲劇學院畢業的小夥子，你知道的。第一份工作，而你就在大溪地，你知道的。但托尼就是照顧我們，我永遠不會忘記他身上的那種特質。我們有一位偉大的導演，來自紐西蘭的羅傑·唐納森。但他和托尼處得不是很好，因為托尼會拍無休止的鏡頭。
I remember one day, 27 takes of hoisting the princess, Tahitian princess up onto the bounty. Oh, God. Like 27 takes and the sun beating down and stuff. And what's the point of my story? It was just great. It was a great experience. But we all started developing that. What's the opposite of cabin fever when you're surrounded by water all the time?
我记得有一天，为了把公主，塔希提公主吊到“赏金号”上，拍了27条。天哪。拍了大概27条，太阳还暴晒什么的。我讲这个故事的意义何在？不过真的很棒。这是一次非常棒的经历。但我们大家开始产生那种情绪了。当四周都是水的时候，什么叫幽闭恐惧症的反义词？
There's a scientific, there's a medical name for it. So if somebody sent you out a newspaper from Britain or Ireland, you would read this from cover to cover. Sure. And someone would, you'd give it to your friend to read to, you know. But this stays, the newspaper's a week old, ten days old. And then you'd start, I'd say, Richard, where's my paper? I said, but you read it, you finished it. It doesn't matter.
有一个科学的，有一个医学名称来称呼它。所以如果有人给你寄一份来自英国或爱尔兰的报纸，你会从头到尾读完它。真的。然后你会，你会把它给你朋友读，你知道的。但这东西留着，报纸已经一周大，十天大了。然后你就会开始，我会说，理查德，我的报纸呢？我说，但你已经看过了，你都看完了。没关系。
I want a bike. So there was, you know, we were there for three months. So we were just all starting to get on each other's nerves. Yeah. If you watch The Bounty today, do you think you would have notes for your performance? Has your style of acting changed over the years that presupposes that you watch what you do? Are you one of those actors that watches what you do? Because some don't like to.
我想要辆自行车。所以，你知道的，我们在那里待了三个月。所以我们开始互相看对方不顺眼了。是的。如果你今天看《叛舰喋血记》，你觉得你会对自己的表演提出意见吗？你的表演风格这些年变了吗？这假设你会看你自己的作品。你是那种会看自己作品的演员吗？因为有些人不喜欢看。
I don't. I do. I like to say it at least once. I mean, if I'm playing the lead, I watch it at least a couple of times. But that's it. This is while you're shooting, right? You'll watch one of the playbacks to see if you're kind of on the right track? No, I don't do that.
我不看。我看。我喜欢至少看一次。我的意思是，如果我演主角，我至少会看个两三次。但也就这样了。这是在你拍摄的时候，对吧？你会看回放来看看自己是不是在正确的轨道上吗？不，我不会那样做。
Unless it's some technical thing where the director needs me to be on the left. And I think, no, I should be on the right of this character, for example. But you'll watch the final product, though. Yeah. Yeah, I would watch it. So what about your style? I just said, I ask that because I get so cringy when I look at the old stuff that I've done. Oh, my God, I do it so differently today because you have such a wide body of work.
除非有什么技术问题，导演需要我站在左边。而我想，不，我应该在这个角色的右边，举个例子。不过你还是会看最终成品。对。对，我会看的。那你的风格呢？我刚才是说，我之所以这么问，是因为当我看到我以前拍的旧东西时，我会觉得尴尬得要命。哦，天哪，我今天的演法和以前大不相同了，因为你有这么丰富的作品。
I'd imagine it would be pretty fun or scary or what for you to look at all the stuff you've done way back when. Oh, God, yeah. It's overacting, isn't it? I don't know if you ever feel that. Anytime I see something, I think, oh, God. That's what I notice I try to do is do less and less every year. Yeah. If I do something, I used to, when I was younger, would watch it once and now I don't watch anything I do.
我能想象，对你来说，回看你以前拍过的所有东西，应该挺有趣，也挺吓人的，或者说是什么感觉？哦，天哪，是的。演过头了，对吧？我不知道你有没有这种感觉。每当我看到什么东西，我都想，哦，天哪。我发现我尽量在做的事情是，每年都少演一点，再少演一点。是的。如果我拍了什么，我年轻时会看一次，现在我什么都不看了。
And if somebody comes up and says, that was really good, I'll check it out. But if nobody says that to me, I don't need to see it. Yeah, but Sean, you were on a very popular comedy sitcom for many years. The Millers? Yes. The Millers that we run together. And you were in one of the top shows for many years and it would be hard to avoid that. I'm going to ask you this.
如果有人走过来对我说，那部演得真好，我会去看看。但如果没有人这么对我说，我就不需要去看它。是的，但香恩，你曾在一个非常受欢迎的喜剧处境剧里演了很多年。《米勒一家》？是的。我们一起播出的《米勒一家》。而且你多年来一直在其中一个顶级节目里，要避开它是很难的。我要问你这个。
So how did you avoid that? You must have seen episodes of your show when it was on the air because it was kind of everywhere. Yeah, Liam, take a seat just for a second. I would, yes, you're right, the reruns when they used to have reruns and all that stuff. It is hard to avoid, but the reboot of the Will and Grace three seasons, I haven't seen one episode. Really? Just like everybody else? I was there.
那你当时是怎么避开的呢？当你的节目在电视上播出时，你肯定看过其中的剧集，因为它到处都是。是的，利亚姆，稍等一下，坐一会儿。我会的，是的，你是对的，当年的重播，当他们经常重播所有这些东西的时候。确实很难避开，但《威尔与格蕾丝》重启的三季，我连一集都没看过。真的吗？就像其他人一样？我当时就在现场。
Just like everyone else. I heard that. So you wouldn't have viewing parties, Sean, if you were to have your stuff? No. Maybe when I was like 27 and I was not up to 20. Liam, I want to ask you something. Because you mentioned a hundred films, it's just an unbelievable accomplishment. There has to be an award for that or something.
就像其他人一样。我听说了。所以你不会搞观影派对的，香恩，如果你要看你的作品的话？不。也许在我27岁左右的时候，我还没有达到20多岁。利亚姆，我想问你件事。因为你提到了上百部电影，这简直是一个令人难以置信的成就。这一定得有个奖什么的。
Or we'll make one for you and send it. By the way, that includes narrating documentaries and stuff like that. And let's not forget the one you did with my sister called Satisfaction where she played a little rock and roll star. Wait, is that it? Oh, yeah. Is that true? Oh, yeah. She played the lead of a band and what did you, I forget.
或者我们为你做一个然后寄给你。顺便说一句，这包括解说纪录片之类的东西。而且别忘了你和我姐姐合作的那部叫《至尊神偷》的电影，她在里面扮演一个小摇滚明星。等等，就是那个吗？哦，是啊。真的吗？哦，是啊。她演一个乐队的主唱，你演的什么，我忘了。
Oh, I saw that movie. Did you play the manager, the band manager or something? I was a retired ex kind of Keith Richards sort of guy. I think they wanted me to manage them. You did not submit that that year for Academy Consideration, did you? No. No. I don't think so.
哦，我看过那部电影。你演的是经理人，乐队经理人还是什么的？我是一个退休的，前基思·理查兹那种类型的家伙。我想他们是想让我来管理他们。你那年没有把那部电影送去参加奥斯卡评选吧？没有。没有。我觉得没有。
Wait, Jason, I remember that film. That was your sister's kind of breakout attempt from Family Times. Yeah, I remember that film too. I think Julia Roberts was in the film too, I think. Julia was in the tape? What was it like 30 years ago? Yeah, it must have been a long time ago. It must have been.
等等，杰森，我记得那部电影。那是你姐姐试图从《成长的烦恼》转型的一部作品。对，我也记得那部电影。我想朱莉娅·罗伯茨也演了那部电影，我想是的。朱莉娅也拍了那个？那是30年前的事了吧？对，一定是很久以前了。肯定是的。
Julia, I know Julia was 19. Wow. So that made me, I was 30, 34. How do you, you're crazy with numbers. How do you remember 31 years old, 19 years old? He's like Will Arnett. Are you one of those people that can remember what you did like April of last year versus June of last year? No, no, that I can't.
朱莉娅，我知道朱莉娅当时19岁。哇。所以这让我，我当时30岁，34岁。你怎么，你对数字太疯狂了。你怎么能记住31岁，19岁？你就像威尔·阿奈特。你是那种能记住去年4月和去年6月做了什么的人吗？不，不，那个我记不住。
Will Arnett. I can't. Names to you. I'm the older I get. I have real trouble with names. Even if I'm calling my sisters, I have three sisters. It's tough. It's tough.
威尔·阿奈特。我记不住。名字对你来说。我年纪越大。我在记名字方面真的有很大困难。即使我叫我姐姐们的名字，我有三个姐姐。这太难了。太难了。
I know. Jason's the same with names. Well, Jason's the same with faces. I was just going to say. Right, Jason? I think I discovered my smallest dog yesterday who, you know, we've had for eight years now. I think he's got facial blindness, right? Whatever that thing is.
我知道。杰森记名字也是这样。好吧，杰森记脸也是这样。我正要说呢。对吧，杰森？我想我昨天发现了我的那只最小的狗，你知道的，我们已经养了八年了。我觉得他有面部识别障碍，对吧？不管那叫什么东西。
Recognizing? He barks at me every day. Sure. And usually about 30 seconds after he just saw me last. And he'll look at me like I'm a stranger that's just broken in through the side window and I'm coming in to do a lot of damage. I'm like, guy, I just fed you. The actor in you wants desperately for him to recognize you. Please.
认人？他每天都对我狂吠。当然。通常是在他刚看到我之后的30秒左右。他看着我的眼神，就像我是个刚从侧窗破门而入、准备大肆破坏的陌生人。我就想，老兄，我刚喂过你啊。你体内的演员之魂非常渴望他能认出你。拜托。
I walk around with my headshot and it's signed and he doesn't want it. I watched you. You always have a stack of headshots with you, which I admire. I think that takes a lot of cuts. Just try to disarm some sort of unfriendly. Yeah. Jason, your dog's interesting. Maybe it's, that is interesting. I adore dogs.
我随身带着我的签名宣传照，但他根本不想要。我看着你。你总是随身带着一叠宣传照，我很佩服这一点。我觉得这需要很大的勇气。只是想解除某种不友善的武装。是的。杰森，你的狗很有意思。也许，这挺有意思的。我很喜欢狗。
That's fascinating. I do too, but not this one. Jason, by the way, speaking of your dog, I met this guy yesterday, you know, Frank, your dog. A top dog? Your top dog. I met a guy yesterday. This is a true story. I forgot to tell you what he said.
太迷人了。我也是，但不是这只。杰森，顺便说一句，说到你的狗，我昨天遇到一个家伙，你知道的，弗兰克，你的狗。顶级狗？你的顶级狗。我昨天遇到一个家伙。这是一个真实的故事。我忘了告诉你他说了什么。
My dog is Jason's dog, Frank's brother. And I said, no kidding. And he said, yeah, the guy who I... First of all, my dog's name is Hank. Nice to meet you. And so his dog is related to my dog, Hank. Now this is my dog's name. Your dog's name is... Petrol.
我的狗是杰森的狗弗兰克的兄弟。我说，不是吧。他说，对，那个家伙……首先，我的狗叫汉克。很高兴认识你。所以他的狗和我的狗汉克有亲戚关系。现在这是我的狗的名字。你的狗的名字是……彼得罗。
Nice try. Peter. You don't remember either. You don't remember either. Shan... Bella. Bella. Bella.
猜得不错。彼得。你也不记得了。你也不记得了。香恩……贝拉。贝拉。贝拉。
So, yeah. Now that's my other dog who's, he recognizes me right away. He's very loving, very lovely. I don't have a problem with him. Yeah. And we all cut you off. Sean, go, please. No, I just was interested in our guest.
所以，是的。现在那是我的另一只狗，他一眼就能认出我。他非常慈爱，非常可爱。我和他之间没有任何问题。对。我们大家都打断了你。香恩，请继续。不，我只是对我们的嘉宾感兴趣。
Favorite color, Liam. Did I guess it? Did I guess it, Sean? No. Now you've told us your funny theater story. What's your funny movie story? He's the worst Liam. I'm so sorry.
最喜欢的颜色，利亚姆。我猜中了吗？我猜中了吗，香恩？没有。既然你已经讲了你那有趣的剧场故事。你有什么有趣的电影故事吗？他真是最糟糕的利亚姆。非常抱歉。
I don't want to get into movie stories, but I'm surprised. Sean hasn't asked this yet because I'm fascinated. One of the great films of all time, Schindler's List, and how that experience came to be for you. Yeah. Well, I was going to ask that too. I know. I know everybody wants to know it,
我不想扯到电影故事上，但我很惊讶。香恩到现在还没问这个，因为我很着迷。史上最伟大的电影之一，《辛德勒的名单》，以及你当年是如何获得那次经历的。是的。嗯，我当时住在洛杉矶，我的经纪人把这个剧本寄给了我，它简直好得惊心动魄又美丽，而且写得极其出色。我当时对史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格有一点了解。
but I don't know any stories. And it's one of my favorite films. Yeah. I was living out in Los Angeles at the time, and my agent sent me this script, which was just breathtakingly horrible and beautiful and incredibly well written. And I knew Steven Spielberg a little bit.
是埃里克·罗斯还是斯蒂芬·扎利安？两个中的一个？史蒂芬·扎利安。对。史蒂芬·扎利安。我在他选角《太阳帝国》时，跟一群小孩一起为史蒂芬试过镜。哦，哇。
Was it Eric Roth or Steven Zalion? One of the two? Steve Zalion. Yeah. Steve Zalion. And I had read for Steven with a bunch of kids when he was casting Empire of the Sun. Oh, wow.
克里斯蒂安·贝尔的第一部电影，对吧？对。我想他记住了我。所以我被邀请去见他，为了《辛德勒的名单》。而且我，你知道的，因为背景设定在20世纪40年代，我租了一套40年代的西装，我还试着把头发剪短之类的。我和史蒂芬在一起待了大约两、两个半小时。史蒂芬拿着一台摄像机。
Christian Bale's first movie, right? Yeah. I guess he remembered me. So I was asked to go in and meet him for Schindler's List. And I had, you know, because of setting the 1940s, I hired a 40 suit, and I tried to keep my hair short and stuff. And I spent about two, two and a half hours with Steven. And Steven had a camera.
房间里只有他和两个人。我准备了电影剧本里的几个小台词。后来结束后，他说，非常感谢。我感觉很好。我想，好吧，如果我没拿到这个角色，我也和我们这个时代最伟大的电影制作人之一相处了两个半、三个小时。是的。
It was just he and I in a room. And I prepared a couple of little speeches from the film, the script. And then after it was over, he said, thank you very much. And I felt great. I thought, well, if I don't get this, I've spent two and a half, three hours, which is one of the great movie makers of our time. Yeah.
然后我去了，是的，我之后去了纽约演一出戏。我必须，我必须再次登上舞台。我以为你要说，然后我去爱德·德贝维克斯餐厅喝了一杯。所以你去纽约演了一出戏。他们让你等了多久？嗯，过了好几个星期。我当时在演那出让我遇到我妻子的戏。
And then I went to, yeah, I went to New York after that to do a play. I had to, I had to get on the stage again. I thought you were going to say, then I went to Ed DeBevix and got a drink. So you go to New York and do a play. How long do you make you wait? Well, it was quite a few weeks. I was doing this play where I met my wife.
那出戏叫《安娜·克里斯蒂》。我遇到了我的妻子，史蒂芬和他的妻子凯特，还有凯特的妈妈来看这出戏。他们演出后去了后台，这真的非常贴心。我打开门，当时我只穿了一半衣服什么的。我说，哦，天哪，史蒂芬，对不起，让我穿件长袍什么的。凯特的妈妈在演出结束后非常激动，眼含热泪，
The play was called Anna Christie. I met my wife and Steven and his wife, Kate, and Kate's mom came to see the play. And they came backstage afterwards, which is very sweet of them. And I opened my door and I was half undressed and stuff. I said, oh my God, Steven, I'm sorry, let me put a rubon or something. And Kate's mom was quite emotional, quite teary after the performance,
看了那场戏之后。我走过去给了她一个拥抱。显然在回程的路上，当他们离开并在开车回家的路上时，凯特对史蒂芬说，这正是辛德勒会做的事。现在，史蒂芬告诉我，不，是你的试镜让你得到了这个角色。但我喜欢“这就是辛德勒会做的事”这个故事。自由平衡男子汉镜头里的那句名言是什么？
the play. And I went and just gave her a hug. Apparently on the way, when they were left and they were driving back home, Kate said to Steven, that's just what Schindler would have done. Now, Steven told me, no, it was your audition that got you the part. But I like the story of that's what Schindler would have done. What's the great quote from the Manly Shot of Liberty balance
当传奇变成事实，就印传版本身？我宁愿相信是因为我拥抱了凯特的妈妈才让我得到了这个角色。太棒了。现在听一段赞助商广告。现在回到节目中。和你合作过，你合作过那么多伟大的导演。你能记起他们当中任何人的什么事吗，我猜斯皮尔伯格肯定排在前列，
when the legend becomes fact, print the legend? I like to think it's because I hugged Kate's mom that got me the part. That's great. And now a word from her sponsor. And now back to the show. Working with you've worked with so many great directors. Can you remember anything that from any of them, I imagine Spielberg would be right near the top of it,
真的让你叹为观止，觉得“啊，这就是伟大导演和优秀导演的区别”？有没有什么特别引人注目的是他或你合作过的其他任何不可思议的导演做过的，他们让片场变得舒适的能力，他们与剧组合作的方式，甚至有没有什么特别关于史蒂芬在那部电影中做的事，因为它是如此精细。
that really kind of took your breath away like, ah, that is the difference in great directing versus good directing. Is there anything that was super noticeable about what he or any of the other incredible directors you've worked with have done their ability to make a set comfortable, the way in which they worked with the crew, anything that stands out maybe even specifically about Steven with that film, because it was just so finely done.
关于史蒂芬，有趣的是，这是他拍的第一部没有使用分镜头剧本的电影。现在他总是使用分镜头剧本，你可以去看看画出来的、关于你要拍什么的卡通分镜头。他没有。而且他在讲述他自己的人民，他的犹太同胞的故事。他紧张得难以置信。他感受到了他所讲述的故事的责任重大。
It was interesting with Steven because it was the first film he had done without using a storyboard. Now he always uses a storyboard and you can go up and see the cartoons drawn of what you're going to shoot. He didn't. And he was telling the story of his people, his Jewish people. And he was incredibly nervous. He felt the responsibility of the story he was telling you.
是的，我记得第一天，我们在纽约这里演完周日下午场的戏。我周一飞过去。据我所记，要么是周二早上，要么是周三早上，大概早上5点半。我们来到了奥斯威辛集中营的大门外，柏林真正的奥斯威辛。我想世界犹太人大会，我想这是正确的名字，
Yeah, and I remember the first day, we finished the play here in New York on Sunday afternoon. I flew out on Monday. And as far as I can remember, it was either Tuesday morning or the Wednesday morning, like 5.30 in the morning. We were at the gates of Auschwitz, the real Auschwitz in Berlin. And I think the World Jewish Congress, I think that's the right name,
没有给史蒂芬在奥斯威辛内部拍摄的许可。但美术设计团队做了一件极其出色的工作。我们在奥斯威辛外面拍摄，但让它看起来就像在奥斯威辛里面一样。对。我记得那个故事。我穿着一件厚重的大衣和帽子，又暖和又舒适，尽管当时冷得难以置信。这辆火车开进来了，所有这些群众演员都出来了，扮演犹太人和带着军犬的德国群众演员。
didn't give Steven permission to shoot inside Auschwitz. But the production design team did a brilliant job. We shot outside of Auschwitz, but made it seem as if it was inside Auschwitz. Right. I remember that story. And I was dressed in a big fur coat and hat and nice and warm, even though it was unbelievably cold. And this train was coming in and all these extras were coming out, as Jewish people and German extras with guard dogs.
这太可怕了。这太可怕了。我记得，我正等着拍我的那场戏。我顺着铁丝网走过去，你知道的，往里面看着那些多年前犹太人被挤在里面的棚屋。我只是看着，布兰科·拉斯蒂格，他是制片人之一，他已经去世了，上帝保佑他，他走到我身边说，你感觉怎么样？
And it was terrifying. It was terrifying. And I remember, I was waiting to do my bit. And I walked down, you know, by the barbed wire fences and looking inside at the huts that, you know, the Jewish people were crammed into all those years ago. And I was just looking and Branko Lustig, who was one of the producers, he's dead and I got dressed him, but he came up to me and said, how do you feel?
我说，是的，我挺好的，布兰科。我很暖和，正期待着开始呢，你知道的。我们正看着那些棚屋，他指着其中一个棚屋说，看到那个了吗，从左数第三个。我现在是瞎编的，但他说，那就是我呆过的地方。不会吧。在六岁的时候。好吧，我当时就崩溃了。
I said, yeah, I'm okay, Branko. I'm warm enough and just looking forward to starting, you know. And we were looking at the huts and he pointed out to a hut and said, see that one there, third one from the left. I'm making this up now, but he said, that's where I was. No way. At the age of six. Well, I just lost it.
哇。是的。我崩溃了。我的膝盖开始发抖，我想，操，这不是在演戏。这不是他妈的电影。我们在这里讲述的是一段历史，而我不配。我一直在对自己说，我他妈的不配。我只是个该死的爱尔兰演员。
Wow. Yeah. I lost it. My knee started to shake and I thought, fuck, this isn't acting. This isn't a fucking movie. This is a piece of history we're telling here and I'm not worthy. I just kept saying to myself, I'm not fucking worthy. I'm a fucking Irish actor.
我本该回爱尔兰去剧院的。我他妈在这里干什么？穿着这件厚重的大衣，来到这里拯救这些犹太人。我只是，这太可怕了。但史蒂芬很好。有一个小场面，我把一个带有很多犹太女孩的女孩拉起来，因为这些囚犯本不应该被送到奥斯威辛。他们应该在我的工厂里工作，因为奥斯卡·辛德勒有这个军工厂。
I should have gone back to Ireland and go into the theater. What the fuck am I doing here? Dressed up in this big fur coat and here to save these Jewish people. I just, it was terrifying. But Stephen was great. And it's a little scene where I pull one of these girls with a lot of Jewish girls up because these prisoners shouldn't have been sent to Auschwitz. They're supposed to be working in my factory because Oscar Schindler had this armaments factory.
他是在那里拯救他们的生命的。否则他们就会死在奥斯威辛。所以我走到这个守卫面前说，你怎么敢这么做？这些人是我的民。他们必须回去。我在发抖。我拉起一个小女孩，我动作太温柔了，因为她快冻僵了。那里有个小女演员。
And he was there to save their lives. Otherwise they were going to die in Auschwitz. So I go up to this guard and say, how dare you do this? These are my people. They have to go back. And I'm shaking. I pulled a little girl up and I was doing it too gently because she was freezing. There's a little actress.
史蒂芬朝我走来说，别装好人了。抓住她。把她拉起来。这里她的生命危在夕。所以我向她道歉，我说，听着，我要相当粗暴地抓住你，把你拉起来，好让这个守卫看到你。她大概只有七八岁大。而我对守卫说的是，
And Stephen came over to me and said, stop the niceness. Grab her. Pull her up. Her life's at stake here. So I apologized to her. I said, look, I'm going to grab you quite roughly and pull you up so that this guard sees you. She was only about seven or eight years of age. And I'm supposed to say to the guard,
我需要这个小女孩的小手，这样他们才能清理军火金属弹壳的内部。但我总是把这台词说不太对。你当时在说德语，对吧？本应该是的。但用英语。不管怎样，我扯远了。杰森，我喜欢这个。所有的导演都不一样。
I need this little girl to small hands so they can clean the inside of metal casings for the armaments. But I could never quite say the line right. You're speaking in German at this point, right? It's supposed to be, yeah. But in English. But anyway, I'm rambling. Jason, I love this. All the directors are different.
听着，利亚姆，你刚让我想起我第一次看那部电影的情景，因为我看过好几次了，就像很多人一样，听你谈论时感到无比震撼，我无法想象那种感觉。那种你在那一刻感受到的责任感扑面而来。我记得当时我在剧院，老切尔西剧院，我想现在不叫那个名字了，在第23街和第八大道交界处，我当时住在纽约。哦，是的。是的，我记得我当时在看那部电影，有这样一个时刻，每个人从火车上下来一片混乱，每个人都在抓狂，没有人知道发生了什么。
Listen, Liam, you just reminded me the first time I saw that film, because I've seen it a few times, like a lot of people in so incredibly moving hearing you talk about, I can't imagine feeling that. And it comes across that sense of responsibility that you felt in that moment. And I remember I was at the theater, the old Chelsea theater is, I don't think it's called that anymore, but on 23rd at 8th Avenue, I was living in New York. Oh, yes. Yeah, and I remember I was seeing that film and there was that moment where there's the chaos of everybody coming off the train and stuff, and everybody's freaking out, nobody knows what's going on.
就在那个时刻，剧院里的火灾警报响了，所以那些小灯在闪烁。有种嗡嗡的声音在响，还有闪烁。这感觉就像它真的发生了一样，你知道的，它成了电影的一部分，剧院里的人们开始抓狂，人们公开哭泣，因为它让一个本来就已经高度紧张的时刻更加紧张了。是的。这让每个人，并且永远改变了那种方式，在那个时刻亲历那种事简直是一种发自肺腑的体验。而且……
And at that very moment, in the theater itself, the fire alarm went off, so they've got those little lights that are blinking. And there's a sound going, woo, woo, and the blinking. And it was almost like it happened, you know, that it was part of the film, and people started freaking out in the theater, and people were openly weeping, because it just heightened an already very heightened moment. Yeah. And it made everybody, and it forever changed the way, it was just such a visceral thing to actually have happened in that moment. And...
是的。是的。你平时会做什么不是非常、非常辛苦的工作，就像你平时做的那样？是的，你还在打拳击吗？那是你日常锻炼的一部分吗？我有一个沙袋。嗯，我有一个健身房，我有时会用沙袋，但我只是喜欢读书。我的意思是，我有一个阅读器，你知道的？真的吗？
Yes. Yeah. What do you get into that is not really, really hard work, like you usually do? Yeah, are you still boxing too? Is that part of your regiment? I have a bag. Well, I have a gym, and I use a bag sometimes, but I just like to read. I mean, I have a reader, you know? Really?
是的。哇，你们俩……我们非常相似，利亚姆。轻松点。嗯……不，利亚姆和我非常相似。我喜欢读书，而且我出门这里就挂着一个沙袋，杰森也有一个沙袋，但他把它藏在马桶后面，他一次只会在那里面待几分钟。
Yeah. Wow, you guys are... We're very similar, Liam. Easy. Well... No, Liam and I are very similar. I like to read, and I also have a bag right out the door here, and Jason has a bag, but he keeps it behind the toilet, and he just goes in there for a couple of minutes at a time.
或者他带着他的某个好莱坞朋友去打沙袋。不过别用得太多，对吧。我得熬过这个夜晚，对吧？利亚姆，我想问这个问题。你沾染过什么毒品？因为事情是这样的。当你……事情是这样的。
Or he plays past the bag with one of his Hollywood friends. But don't use too much of it, yeah. I got to get through the night, yeah? Liam, I would like to ask this question. What drugs have you dabbled in? Because here's the thing. When you... Here's the thing.
他是我们的秘密武器，利亚姆。他最棒了。继续说。对不起，香恩。不，请便。当你做着，就像你说的，100件事，比如100部电影什么的，纪录片和各种作品。当然。你在旅行，时差，夜间拍摄，以及这些事情。
He's our secret weapon, Liam. He's the best. Keep going. Sorry, Sean. No, please. When you're doing, like you said, 100 things, like 100 films or whatever, docs and everything. Sure. And you're traveling, and the time changes, and the night shoots, and this stuff.
当你年轻的时候，你会想，我怎么才能熬过去？你肯定参与过某种东西来熬过所有那些数量庞大、没完没了的电影……你是辛迪·亚当斯吗？这到底是怎么回事？你想让他承认吸毒吗？我来跟你谈谈……我们谈过我们吃过的毒品。说吧。
When you were younger, you're like, how am I going to get through this? You had to have partaken into something to get through all of those many, many films of just endless... Are you Cindy Adams? What is going on? Do you want him to admit to drug use? I'll talk to you about the... We've talked about the drugs we took. Go ahead.
告诉罗娜·巴雷特你最后一次参与某种非法吸毒是什么时候。如果你不想回答，可以不回答。我敢打赌你现在保持精力充沛全靠那些锻炼。我敢打赌你吃得很好。听起来你通过大量的阅读保持着理智和健康。听起来你并没有做很多让自己慢下来或伤害自己的事情，对吧？不，差不多就是这样。这很无聊。
Tell Rona Barrett what the last time you participated in some sort of illicit drug use. You don't want to answer that if you don't want to. I'll bet the way you stay up in peppy nowadays is all that exercise. I'll bet you eat well. Sounds like you're staying nice and sane with lots of reading. It doesn't sound like you're doing a lot of things to slow yourself down or hurt yourself, huh? No, that's about it. It's very boring.
我的意思是，我喜欢溪钓。只要有机会我就会去做。你应该和吉米·吉摩尔搭上线。吉米·吉摩尔。吉米是。是的。吉米·吉摩尔今年晚些时候会很大规模地……我不知道什么时候。
I mean, I fly fish. I love to do that whenever I get a chance. You should hook you up with Jimmy Kimmel. Jimmy Kimmel. Jimmy is. Yes. Jimmy Kimmel is large sometime this year. I don't know when.
我本来去年要去的。我们有一大群人准备过几个月去。我们要给你发邀请函。来吧。我们今年夏天要去。然后你就可以教我那个了。真的吗？是的。
I was supposed to go last year. There's a big group of us going in a few months. We're going to send you the invite. Come on up. We're going to go this summer. Then you can teach me that. Are you really? Yeah.
我向上帝发誓。看起来壮观极了。太惊艳了。他在这方面真的做得很好。我等不及了。太棒了。我等不及了。等等，香恩，你还想知道利亚姆有没有吸过毒，对吧？
I swear to God. It looks spectacular. It's stunning. He's really done a great job with it. I can't wait. That's terrific. I can't wait. Wait, Sean, do you still want to know about Liam's drug use, right?
不。对不起，香恩。不，不，不。利亚姆，你不用回答他那些垃圾问题。这很有趣。不，这很公平。我没有谈论这个。当然，当我在爱尔兰的剧院时，演出结束后，我们会去当地的酒吧。
No. Sorry, Sean. No, no, no. You don't have to answer his garbage questions, Liam. It's interesting. No, it's fair enough. I'm not talking about it. Certainly when I was in Ireland in the theater, after shoes, we'd go to the local pub.
我非常喜欢吉尼斯啤酒。绝对喜欢它。然后你到了某个年龄，它就会转化为你的赘肉。你知道我的意思吗？你还在发胖，就像，哦，天哪。我改喝红葡萄酒了宿。我绝对喜欢那个。那个长胖少一点，但宿醉没那么好受，对吧？
I adored Guinness. Absolutely adored it. Then you turn a certain age and it sticks to you. You know what I mean? You're still putting on weight and it's like, oh my God. I switched to red wine. I absolutely adored that. Does that put that puts on less weight, but there's the hangovers not as fun, right?
全都是糖。我八年多前戒酒了。是的，刚过八年多。哇。我必须说我并不怀念它。我也是。我们不喝酒。我戒酒基本上是为了虚荣。
All that sugar. I stopped drinking eight. Yeah, just over eight years ago. Wow. I must say I don't miss it. Same here. We don't drink. I don't drink basically out of vanity.
我可以承认这一点。但没关系。我们所有人的剩余恶习是什么？我的意思是，这对我来说太可悲了。就像糖还有脆的、咸的零食。你知道的，杰伊？是的。哦。
I can admit that. But that's okay. What's the remaining vices for all of us? I mean, it's pathetic with me. It's like sugar and like crunchy, salty snacks. And you know, Jay? Yeah. Oh.
高尔夫？不，软糖。哦，对，对，对，软糖。我的意思是，那算恶习吗？我不知道。现在这合法的。杰森，你尝过那些吗，利亚姆？你尝过含THC的软糖吗？
Golf? No, hot gummies. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, gummies. I mean, is that advice? I don't know. It's legal nowadays. Jason, have you tried those, Liam? Have you tried the gummies with the THC in it?
还有CBD。不，我吃的是含CBD和一点褪黑素的软糖。我每天晚上都吃那些。是的，能让你直接睡着。我确实有睡眠问题。杰森还有一些别的东西给你。而且第一份是免费的。第一份是免费的。
And the CBD. No, I have gummies with the CBD on a little bit of melatonin. I take those every night. Yeah, puts you right out. I do have trouble sleeping. Jason's got some other stuff for you. And the first one's free. The first one's free.
我等会儿就待在这儿。让我记一下你的邮政信箱什么的。现在还有人用邮政信箱吗？香恩，你喜欢大麻。你偶尔喜欢抽大麻。嗯，我已经好几年没抽了。我不能再抽了。但我确实也吃软糖。
I'm just going to just stay on afterwards. Let me get your PO box or something. People still use PO boxes? Sean, you like weed. You like to smoke weed every once in a while. Well, I haven't smoked in years. I can't smoke anymore. But I do eat the gummies as well.
也吃软糖。你不介意那个。那你的另一个恶习是什么？你不喝咖啡。你喝咖啡吗？利亚姆，你是个咖啡迷吗？不，我戒掉咖啡因了。我知道。
The gummies as well. You don't mind that. And then what's your other advice? You don't drink coffee. Do you drink coffee? Liam, are you a coffee guy? No, I give up caffeine. I know.
太他妈无聊了。不，你非常有自律。而我一直拿着这个。这是一个马克杯。那是什么？好吧，这是一个斯坦利马克杯。我用其中一个。它能让我的黑脱咖啡因茶保持温热五到六个小时。
So fucking boring. No, you're very disciplined. And I'm constantly this. It's a mug. What is that? Okay, it's a Stanley mug. I do one of them. It keeps my black decaf tea hot for five or six hours.
这也是我的小安全毯。当然。我把它带到片场。我尽量把它塞进每一部电影里。哦，你真的这么做。你尽量把它塞进去。你有没有用它砸过别人的脸？因为你在那个精准的……
And it's also my little security blanket. Sure. I take it on set. I try and get it into every movie. Oh, you do. You try to get it. Do you ever smash guys in the face with it? Because you're in the exact...
包括《诸神之战》。你没有。你在……你现在有什么觉得尴尬的事情吗？你在看什么烂电视节目吗？你是在……你说你读很多书。你在读什么连环画，是你……
Including Clash of the Titans. You don't have them. What are you... Are you doing anything currently that you're embarrassed of? Any crappy TV you're watching? Are you... You say you read a lot. Are you reading a comic book that you're not...
是你不好意思向任何人透露的？没有。犯罪小说。我依然迷恋我的北欧黑色犯罪小说。哦，不。威尔来了。哦，像内斯博？内斯博和那些人？
That you're not proud to reveal to anybody? No. Crime. I'm still into my Nordic noir crime. Oh, no. Here comes Will. Oh, like Nesbo? Nesbo and those guys?
是的，内斯博很不错。还有海宁·曼凯尔。他大约四年前去世了。他简直非凡。我刚刚在我的最后一部电影里扮演了菲利普·马洛。所以，大失所望的是，我以前从未读过雷蒙德·钱德勒的作品。所以在做准备时，我想我读了他大部分的作品。在播客里拥有最烟嗓声音的威尔遇到了对手。
Yeah, Nesbo's good. And Henning Mankell. He passed away about four years ago. He's just extraordinary. And I just played Philip Marlowe in my last film. So I had never read, much to my shame, Raymond Chandler before. So I read most of his stuff for preparation, I guess. Will has met his match with the smokiest voice on this podcast.
是的。哦，天哪。你们做过任何配音工作吗？我们一起拍过三部电影。这应该……还有另一个……而且我们从未见过面。而且，我们之前谈论过雷夫·费因斯。
Yes. Oh, God. Do you guys do any voiceover work? We've done three films together. It should be... And the other... And we've never met. And also, we were talking before about Ray Fiennes.
他也演过《乐高大电影：蝙蝠侠》，在里面为我的蝙蝠侠演阿尔弗雷德。我们有很多对手戏。哦，我不知道那个。是的，我们还没见过面。我真是个粉丝。我迫不及待了。太棒了。利亚姆，除了偶尔的动画片，你还做过其他配音工作吗？
He also was in Lego Batman and played Alfred to my Batman. And we had a lot of scenes together. Oh, I didn't know that. Yeah, we have yet to meet. And I'm just such a fan. I can't wait. That's terrific. Liam, do you do any voiceover work other than the animation every once in a while?
你是电视上某种特定产品的声音吗？你做过什么商业广告吗？没有。我们一直在谈论GMC卡车。是的。幸运的是，他还在继续做。我不做。我做过纪录片，而且我做过相当多这类作品。
Are you the voice of any particular product on television? You do any commercial stuff? No. We'll talk about GMC trucks all the time. Yes. Lucky for them, he's still doing it. I don't. I've done documentaries and I've done quite a few of those.
产品广告，没有。你真该去，天哪。利亚姆，你会赚得盆满钵满的。你做过肯·伯恩斯的任何纪录片吗？是的，我做过，实际上。在封锁期间，我做了……哦，有一部关于安妮·弗兰克的要上映了。哦，太酷了。
The products, no. You should, my God. Liam, you would clean up. Have you done any of the Ken Burns documentaries? Yes, I have, actually. During lockdown, I did... Oh, there's one on Anne Frank that's coming out. Oh, that's cool.
我扮演安妮·弗兰克的父亲，只有几句台词。还有目前关于本杰明·费兰克的，我想，正在制作中。我有一个小角色。那部上映了吗，还是没有？还没。肯·伯恩斯是个天才。他上过这个节目。他是个不可思议的嘉宾。
I played Anne Frank's father just a few lines. And the current one on Benjamin Franklin, I think, is combined. I have a small part. Is that one out yet or no? Not yet. Ken Burns is a genius. He's been on the show. He was an incredible guest.
我们邀请过他。我们邀请过他，对，对。你确实邀请过。对，对，对。他那么博学，而且他只是……你看过《阿里》吗？《阿里》。我还没看过那部。
We had him on. We had him on, yeah. You did. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And he's so erudite and he's just... Did you see the Ali? The Ali. I haven't seen that one yet.
我必须说，穆罕默德·阿里曾经是、现在是、将来也永远是我的偶像。一直是。是的，那部纪录片太不可思议了。他拍的关于第二次世界大战的那部也很不可思议，叫《战争》。第二次世界大战，还有美国内战，我每年至少看两遍。太不可思议了。而且它上映，我不知道，大概是25年前左右吧。好吧，我很高兴你喜欢穆罕默德·阿里，因为你曾经是，我之前提到过，
I have to say, and Muhammad Ali was, is, always will be my idol. Always was. Yeah, that documentary is incredible. The one he did on World War II is incredible, too, called The War. World War II, but the American Civil War, I have two warts that at least once a year. It's incredible. And it came out, I don't know, 25 years ago or something. Well, I love that you love Muhammad Ali because you were, and I mentioned before,
你以前打过一点拳击，当过几年业余拳击手？是的，我9岁时开始的。我想我最后一次打比赛是在我17岁左右吧。哦，天哪，那个年纪被打会受伤的。是的，开始疼了。是的，因为小孩子们打来打去没什么，但当你成为青少年时，如果你真的要打架，你必须非常生气，因为你可能会受伤。所以，但是拳击，所以你作为一个年轻成年人或成年人在打拳击，对吧？
you did box a little bit, amateur box for a couple years there? Yeah, I started when I was nine. I think I had my last fight when I was like 17 or something. Oh my God, that's old enough to get hurt. Yeah, it was starting to hurt. Yeah, because like kids punch each other all the time, but then you become a teenager and you've got to really be pissed off if you're going to get into that because you can get hurt. So, but boxing, so you were boxing as a young adult or adult, right?
嗯，在13、14岁的时候，我开始猛长。我的意思是，我身高六英尺四英寸，我……这太惊人了。然后我想我当时大约六英尺三英寸左右。拳头，是的，开始疼了，你知道的。我记得有一次来，我们在爱尔兰老家的小镇上的小地方会堂里有一个锦标赛。我在和这个家伙比赛，我实际上赢了那场比赛，但在我的内心深处，我知道。我并没有赢得那场比赛。
Well, at the age of 13, 14, I started to shoot up. I mean, I'm six foot four and I... That's amazing. Then I guess I was about six foot three or something. Punches were, yeah, they were starting to hurt, you know? And I remember once coming, we had a tournament in our little local parochial hall in my hometown back in Ireland. And I was boxing this guy and I actually won the fight, but I felt my heart of hearts. I didn't win that fight.
但当我走下擂台时，我的教练说，下楼把衣服穿上，我当时……还有整理一下你的脸。但我不知道他是什么意思。衣服。哦，不。下去。这感觉很诡异。
But when I came out of the ring, my trainer said, go downstairs and put your clothes on and I was... And fix your face. But I didn't know what he meant. Clothes. Oh, no. Go down. It was weird.
这就像是一种奇怪的脑震荡，你知道的？所以那是我的最后一场比赛。我足够清醒，心想，操这事，我得离开这儿。你知道的，我们的一个朋友，丽莎·库卓，制作了一个节目叫《你是谁？》，它会追溯你的祖先。她在拍摄过程中狠狠地打了你的脸。而我所有的祖先，你知道的，来自爱尔兰，我也是爱尔兰人。我们去了爱尔兰。
And that was like a kind of a strange concussion, you know? So that was my last fight. I knew enough to think, fuck this, I'm getting out of this. You know, I did a friend of ours, Lisa Kudrow, produced this show called Who Do You Think You Are? And it traces your ancestry. She hit you hard in the face during the shooting of that. And all of my ancestors, you know, from Ireland, I'm Irish as well. And we went over to Ireland.
每个人都是酒鬼和暴徒。每个人都在打架，而且跟所有人打架。好吧，我们走吧。这真是一句名言。谢谢你，香恩。不，我的祖先。谢谢你，香恩。我的祖先。
Everybody is a drunk and a thug. Everybody fought and just fights everybody. Well, there we go. There's a great quote. Thanks, Sean. No, of my ancestors. Thanks, Sean. Of my ancestors.
你的祖先，不是这个国家的所有人。不，不是所有爱尔兰人。我所有的祖先都只是暴徒和酒鬼。这就好像，为什么每个人，我不知道，每个人似乎都、都喜欢打架。他们是哪儿的人，香恩？你家人在哪儿，嘿？丁格尔和……哦，丁格尔。
Your ancestors, not everyone in the country. No, not everybody Irish. All of my ancestors were just thugs and drunks. And it's like, why is everybody, I don't know, everybody just seems to be, loves to be in fights. Where are they from, Sean? Where do your family, hey? Dingle and... Oh, Dingle.
太美了。……凯里郡。是的。是的。到处都是。你还回那里去吗，香恩？就为了我拍的那个节目。就为了打架。
Beautiful. ...County Carry. Yeah. Yeah. All around. You ever go back there, Sean? Just for the show I did. Just to fight.
那里太漂亮了，对吧？哦，难以置信。我觉得它就像……哦，丁格尔。丁格尔非常、非常特别。我外公来自丁格尔。他曾经是……
Just to fight. It's so pretty over there, right? Oh, it's unbelievable. I think it's like the... Oh, Dingle. Dingle's very, very special. My grandfather's from Dingle. And he was...
那里出产的水果很美。丁格尔莓。你尝过吗？不，威尔。我在想别的。你确实是。利亚姆，我们占用了你太多时间了。我们可以跟你聊到永远。
Beautiful fruit from there. Dingleberries. Have you tried? No, Will. I'm thinking of something else. You are. Liam, we've taken way too much of your time. We could talk to you forever.
你真是一个迷人的人。而且是其中一位，如此伟大的表演者。我对你的才华叹为观止。哦，闭嘴吧。谢谢你……不，而且人也这么好。是的。所以谢谢你在你的休息日抽出时间陪我们。
You're just such a fascinating guy. And one of those, just such a great performer. And I'm just in awe of your talent. Oh, shut up. Thank you for... No, but I was such a kind man, too. Yeah. So thank you for spending some time with us on your off day here.
是的。谢谢你，利亚姆。杰森，我能跟你说吗，我知道几年前、三年前我在花园见到你时我对你说过这个，不是吗？请代我向你的母亲维多利亚问好。哦，天哪。现在他在炫耀了。这家伙是世界上最好的人。
Yeah. Thank you, Liam. Jason, can I say to you, I know I said this to you before when I saw you at the garden a couple of years ago, three years ago, wasn't it? Please give Victoria your mom my love. Oh, my God. Now he's showing off. This guy is the nicest guy in the world.
他有一次在泛美航空的航班上遇到我母亲。她曾是泛美航空的空姐。20年后，他撞见了。他以前从未见过我，但我猜她在他遇到她时曾提到过我是她的儿子。所以这是20年后。我们在麦迪逊广场花园看一场游骑兵队的比赛。我看到了利亚姆·尼森。
He meets my mother one time on a Pan Am flight. She was a flight attendant for Pan Am. 20 years later, he runs into me. He's never met me before, but I guess she had mentioned, when she had met him, that I was her son. So this is 20 years later. We're back at a ranger game at Madison Square Garden. And I see Liam Neeson.
我就想，哦，天哪。我完全忘了我母亲曾提过她遇到过他。他拦住我。他说，嘿，嘿，你是杰森。我X年前在飞机上遇到过你母亲。她怎么样？她还好吗？他甚至还记得她的名字？这彻底把我震撼到了。
I'm like, oh, my God. I'd totally forgotten that my mother had said anything that she'd met him. He stops me. He says, hey, hey, you're Jason. I met your mother X number of years ago on a plane. And how is she? Is she doing new remembered her name? It just knocked me out.
然后当我把这件事告诉我母亲时，她哭了整整一个星期。我的意思是，是的。所以非常感谢你成为这样一个善良的人。不，请别这样。我只是……请，请代我向他们问好。我一定会告诉她的。这确实是一件事，我记不太清了，杰森，
And then when I told my mother that, she cried for a week. I mean, yeah. So thank you so much for being such a kind man. No, please. I'm just in to you. Please, please give them my love. I will tell her for sure. And it's something, and I can't quite remember Jason,
但这大概是从洛杉矶飞往伦敦的航班，泛美航空，当然现在已经不存在了。或者从伦敦飞往洛杉矶，我能记住。我当时，我非常脆弱，不是因为我害怕飞行。我没有。有些事情正在发生，出于某种原因，维多利亚，你的母亲，在我身上发现了什么，
but it was a flight from either Los Angeles to London, Pan Am, which doesn't exist, of course. Or from London to LA, I can remember. And I was just, I was very vulnerable, not because I have a fear of flying. I don't. Something was happening, and for some reason, Victoria, your mom, spotted something in me,
她就照顾了我。是的。她时不时会给我拿茶，照顾我。我永远不会忘记。你知道的，我，她曾是……看看这两个家伙。非常特别。一直在写笑话。
and she just took care of me. Yeah. She'd bring me tea and take on me every so often. I'll just never forget it. You know, I was, she was... Look at both these guys. Very special. Just writing jokes.
你一说“照顾我”，他们俩就在四秒钟内写了大约六个笑话。好吧，幸运的是，他接着说“端来了一杯茶”。幸好他这么说了。哦，他们放下笔了。我不是故意要，是的。她非常随和。是的。
As soon as you said, take care of me, both of them wrote about six jokes in four seconds. Well, luckily, he followed up and said with a cup of tea. Luckily, he said that. Oh, they put their pens down. I didn't mean to, yeah. She was very accommodating. Yeah.
嗯，这太甜了。太棒了。再次感谢，利亚姆，我是你的超级粉丝，非常感谢你的时间。是的，这真是个荣幸。谢谢你。老实说，是的。能和你们三个人谈话是我的荣幸。非常感谢。谢谢。
Well, that's very sweet. It's so great. And again, Liam, such a fan, and thank you so much for your time. Yeah, it was such an honor. Thank you. Honestly, yeah. It was an honor to talk with you,
你在我联系劳拉之前跟她打个招呼好吗？我一定会的。我太喜欢她了。我想她五月份要去爱尔兰拍一部电影。哦，真的吗？我要去那儿和我最亲爱的朋友基兰·海因斯拍一部电影。哦，真的。我不想在多尼戈尔拍电影。
the three of you. Thank you so much. Thanks. Can you say hi to Laura if you talked to her before I do? I sure will. I love her so much. She's going over to Ireland, I think,
你在里面没杀任何人吧？哦，是的。你杀了。是的，当然。相当多。相当多，他说。你在想什么？他接了那个角色。公众形象嘛。拜访一下。
in May to shoot a film. Oh, really? I'm going over there to shoot a film with my best dear friend, Kieran Hines. Oh, yeah. I don't want to shoot a film in Donegal. You're not killing anybody in that, are you? Oh, yeah.
伟大的利亚姆·尼森。非常感谢你，我们的朋友。谢谢你，老兄。谢谢你们，伙计们。你们能做这个太好了。谢谢你，利亚姆。太棒了。谢谢，男孩们。
You are. Yeah, of course. Quite a few. Quite a few, he says. What are you thinking? He took the part. There's the public athlete. Come on.
保重。再见，老兄。回头见。伟大的利亚姆·尼森。当他出现在屏幕上时，我就想，什么？这太……太有标志性了。
The great Liam Neeson. Thank you so much, our friend. Thank you, pal. Thanks, guys. It's so nice of you to do this. Thank you, Liam. That's great. Thanks, boys.
这太疯狂了。当我像，我想让他上这个节目。然后他们说，迈克尔·MGT说，是的，我们要请利亚姆·尼森。他要来。我想着，
Take care. Bye-bye, pal. See you later. The great Liam Neeson. When he came on the screen, I was like, what? That's so... Like iconic.
这真的会发生吗？太疯狂了。是的。你是怎么做到的，威利？是的。我不知道。我完全不知道。我想他觉得，你知道的，
It's so crazy. When I was like, I wanted to have him on the show. And then they said, and Michael MGT said, yeah, we're going to have Liam Neeson. He's going to do it. And I thought like,
我的意思是，他稍微认识你一点，而且他是你的超级粉丝。他谈到上次在花园看到我们，他想来打个招呼。他做到了。他的新电影《记忆》将于4月29日上映，也就是……
is this really going to happen? That's crazy. Yeah. How'd you do that, Willie? Yeah. I don't know. I have no idea. I think that he thought, you know,
这真的要发生吗？太疯狂了。是啊。威利，你是怎么做到的？是啊。我不知道。我完全不知道。我想他当时觉得，你知道的，
I mean, he knew you a little bit and he was such a fan. He talked about seeing us at the garden another time and he wanted to come say hi. And he did not. And his new movie, Memory, comes out April 29th, which is...
我的意思是，他稍微认识你一点，而且他是你的超级粉丝。他谈到过在麦迪逊广场花园看过我们的演出，他想来打个招呼。但他没来。他的新电影《记忆》将于4月29日上映，也就是……
I didn't even get a chance to ask him about Star Wars. I know, Sean. Too bad there's not enough Star Wars in the world. I know. Thank God. It's such a shame that we never
我甚至都没机会问他关于《星球大战》的事。我知道，肖恩。太遗憾了，世上没有足够多的《星球大战》。我懂。谢天谢地。真遗憾我们从来没有
had an opportunity to talk about fucking Star Wars. He was in so many Star Wars movies. And then he was like, he was one of those stormtroopers in Force Awakens. And you spent your time with Wrath of the Titans,
有机会聊聊他妈的《星球大战》。他演了那么多《星球大战》电影。然后他就像，《原力觉醒》里的某个冲锋队员。而你却把时间花在了《诸神之怒》上，
the sequel to Clash of the Titans. That's right. You're going to lose your card. Sean, I loved... I really, out of deference to you, I wanted to start it off by asking about theater stories because...
《诸神之战》的续集。没错。你快失去影迷卡了。肖恩，我喜欢……真的，出于对你的尊重，我想以询问剧场故事作为开场，因为……
Thank you. Because he started in the theater. I know, I love that. Thank you. Yeah, I love that. I love... You'd think people would have, like, at the ready...
谢谢你。因为他是从剧场起步的。我知道，我喜欢这个。谢谢你。是的，我喜欢这个。我喜欢……你以为人们会随时准备好……
Well, it turns out, it does start to feel like the only embarrassing things in the theater happened to you. Yeah. And Chris and Chenoweth. Maybe that's true. And the time that you...
好吧，结果证明，剧场里唯一让人尴尬的事情似乎都发生在你身上。是的。还有克里斯和切诺维斯。也许是真的。还有你那次……
Poisoned Chris and Chenoweth. I forgot how the story went. But... Maybe she just had an anxiety attack because the curtain call was such complicated blocking. So we'll just go back. So you came from either side of the...
毒害了克里斯和切诺维斯。我忘了故事是怎么样的了。但是……也许她只是因为谢幕调度太复杂而焦虑发作。所以我们倒回去。所以你从……的两边来
So it was sort of like a by-entrance? Was it a by-entrance? Oh! A what? A by-entrance? Wait, wait, wait, wait. Are we done? Bye!
所以有点像旁侧出场？是旁侧出场吗？哦！什么？旁侧出场？等等，等等，等等，等等。我们结束了吗？再见！
Bye! I don't endorse it. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by
再见！我不支持这个。Smart。Less。SmartLess 是由 Rob Armjurf、Bennett Barbaco 和 Michael Grant Terry 100% 有机手工制作的。
Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Grant Terry. Smart. Less. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts. Or you can listen to it right now,
SmartLess。我们的下一期节目将在两周后发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方听到。或者你现在就可以收听，
early on Amazon Music. Or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry App. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 Amazon Music 上提前收听。或者通过在 Apple Podcasts 或 Wondry App 上订阅 Wondry Plus 来提前收听并免广告。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。